the on smoking and teenagers and you
are
we're very happy as well that you're
with us this morning let me tell you
about what's coming up next as you know
if you've been watching c-span over the
past couple of weeks we've been
re-airing in their entirety the waco
hearings and that's because when these
hearings first occurred the
congressional sessions were very long
and we weren't able to bring them to you
on a regular basis so we are um more
than midway through our rearing of these
today you will be hearing from the
testimony from larry potts the former
assistant director of the fbi and gas
experts from the fbi and the u.s army
command this is the eighth day
of uh hearings and
and we will continue throughout this
week altogether there are 10 days
on the on the docket this uh today's
hearing lasts a little more than four
hours they'll be running until just
about 2 pm eastern time so we will now
begin today's coverage of the waco
hearings on the house side of capitol
hill
today gets into our seventh day of
oversight hearings on executive branch
conduct
at waco and this probably to everyone's
great disappointment
will be a fairly short day in other
words we hope to be done
uh by one o'clock uh if we are not done
with the panel at one
um there is a markup that will go on we
think between one and three
we will then com
recess uh
subject to the call of the chair for
approximately two hours reconvene
hopefully around three and then finish
up
in any ways
analysis i think that's a short day
we will be
having short openings by the chairs and
the ranking members
and
we will only have one panel today
we have to question a
central and much discussed group
of a very important
group of
of major people fbi decision makers
we'll hear from mr larry potts the
former assistant director of the fbi
criminal investigations division he was
a key person at the events at waco
we'll hear from two individuals we heard
from from yesterday
mr jeff jamar the special agent in
charge and on-scene commander at waco
and mr brian sage the first
fbi hostage negotiator on the scene at
waco
we heard from these two gentlemen
yesterday but today we'll hear from them
on a different topic
the fbi decision to insert cs gas into
the davidian compound
finally we will hear from two other
central decision makers
below the attorney general and the
president
at the department of justice they are mr
anthony betts the chief the fbi's unit
chief of domestic terrorism
and someone who researched cs gas for
the attorney general
and mr dick rogers an assistant special
agent in charge and the leader of the
fbi's hostage rescue team
i want to say that this is a
high-ranking group these individuals are
central to the justice department and
they're essential to the events at waco
they are here on their own
volition uh and voluntarily and that
they've come to help us try and sort out
the many unanswered questions and
unsettled facts
as a joint subcommittee performing our
constitutional duty of oversight we are
glad that they have come before us and
we sincerely hope to get to the bottom
of what happened and why the decision
was made to usc to use cs gas on over 80
americans
in this process we think we have come a
long way we've learned new and important
facts and again yesterday and have put a
string in of very late nights
we and the epa and you had to be here to
understand the significance of that
comment
but uh it was it's been quite a session
today we will explore in public for all
america to see the reasoning that went
into the disastrous decision to insert
cs gas into the davidian compound and to
do so with tanks and hundreds of
canisters ferret rounds
we'll question again the timing and the
substance of key pre-gassing
conversations between
fbi personnel at waco and those in
washington we will question who spoke to
the attorney general and who spoke with
those close to her
we will ask who decided to use tanks who
gave the order to knock down walls who
sent in dangerous cs gas that ultimately
killed infants and young children
we'll begin to find out who coordinated
those facts who hasten them and why
those facts were chosen
were there even vaguely viable
alternatives to what was done
were they rejected at least we will ask
those questions
thinking about it last night occurred to
me that the american people have always
appreciated persistence and persistence
in the name of truth well there's
nothing more important
if no one ever asks these questions a
lot of significant significant national
problems would never have been dug into
and brought to light
in almost every case the result of a
sincere oversight effort has been
constructive
of course difficult questions take extra
courage especially when you ask them of
an institution as large and respected as
a department of justice
but people of good faith conscience
conviction patriotic and interested
americans want their questions answered
and they want and they and they need
this additional information
as we stay the course i think you'll
find that today's fresh panel
produces some new findings as we get
closer and closer to the whole picture
of what happened and why
today will be a day where we fit in some
new pieces into the puzzle we owe this
truth-seeking function to the american
people we serve them and we do that
every day
with emerging assad we will get the
whole picture assembled or as close as
our congressional oversight role will
allow and we thank you all we have a
great deal of respect for the institute
institution you serve thank you for
being here this morning chair now
recognizes and introduces the
co-chairman of the joint subcommittees
and chairman of the judiciary
committee's crime subcommittee our good
friend bill mccollum from florida well
thank you very much mr chairman i want
to welcome our panel this morning as we
do begin our seventh day of these
hearings and about a very important part
of this the formulation of this assault
plan and the rationale behind why it was
necessary but before we do that i want
to at least put the last couple of days
of hearings in somewhat of a perspective
at least as i see it
we have walked through very carefully
yesterday a
long and lengthy hearing on the fbi's
beginning role in the negotiations in
the siege and what led up to the assault
that occurred on april 19th
i think from that lengthy discussion
yesterday it has become apparent to
anybody who is watching or listening to
this that most of what if not
all of
what the fbi was doing on the scene was
perfectly
up to the keeping of the standards that
we would expect from our fbi uh we've
been very proud of what we've heard in
regard to most of this and i think that
all of us up here on this panel both
sides of the aisle want you and the fbi
to know that
i think what we're left with after
yesterday both in that panel and on the
discussion of cs gas by those who
testified in the second panel last night
as to what its effects might be leave us
with a couple of lingering questions
that are broad in nature not necessarily
the only questions because some of
course about how this assault developed
and what happened
as we went into it may well lead to
other questions but the two questions
that stand out more than anything else
have to do with the advice and
information that was provided to the
attorney general
and perhaps questions that might go to
the judgment of those who made the
ultimate decisions
obviously the attorney general and if
anyone else was participating in it
their judgment as well
the questions center on the issue of
whether or not in the negotiations
process the attorney general fully
understood
the status of the final days of the
negotiations that is
did she have a sense that was accurate
with respect to what mr tagueran the
attorney representing david korish
thought uh was the
opportunity to bring courage and his
crew out after the 14th of april before
the insertion of the gas on the 19th
was there indeed information sufficient
in her hands to make the judgment call
she made that negotiations were truly at
an impasse and that to go further would
be futile
there are serious questions raised as to
whether or not that was the case i don't
doubt for one minute that the fbi
figures involved that we have testifying
before us believe that there was an
impasse believe that david korish would
not under any circumstances come out
that indeed that he wanted to be a
martyr uh there are however others who
presented rather compelling testimony
that they did not believe that the fbi
at that moment and having been there for
many many days and having seen david
korish reject
and not live up to his commitments to
come out on other occasions was really
listening when they believed that korish
had found a way through his own
interpretations of the book of
revelations and the seven seals and his
own religious views to not be a martyr
but rather instead to be somebody who
came out
or who had an opportunity to be the
messenger of god rather than to be the
martyr
whether or not those interpretations are
accurate is beside the point at this
juncture the question is whether or not
the full flavor of the status of this
opportunity and this state of mind and
the belief of those who were involved in
that was presented to the attorney
general for her decision making the
second question that's arisen has to do
with a cs gas question
and that is whether or not
the attorney general really had
sufficient data and information to make
the decision on the gas
did she simply have one outlook on it
did she fully understand the
ramifications of what this would mean to
children potentially not necessarily
that it was so we had testimony
yesterday that testing simply hadn't
been done on children
that we don't have a lot of information
or data but that there certainly is
scientific evidence to indicate that if
a child takes in this gas
it can affect a child quite differently
especially small children and the
potential for vomiting the potential for
perhaps even dying from asphyxiation as
a result of either vomiting or the gas
itself was there
the degree to which that was taken into
consideration or understood by the
attorney general her decision making
and those of who around her is not at
all clear and i certainly hope that
that's clarified as we move through the
next couple of days
this was a crucial decision obviously
the lives of a lot of people were at
stake and we would like very much on
this panel to know the answer to those
questions and to that judgment call
about what the attorney general really
knew and what she didn't obviously
she'll be here with us on monday to
explain what she did and didn't know
herself but it's very important that we
walk through the process
to gather as much background on on that
and for her as well as for us at this
point in time today uh as
chairman zelloff has indicated we're
looking forward to hearing from those
who planned the gas attack and the
assault and uh better understand why it
was done and what was anticipated uh not
just from the standpoint of the gas but
the standpoint of the tactics that were
involved in this thank you very much mr
zelda
thank you mr mccollum chair now
recognizes the ranking minority member
of the crime subcommittee friend chuck
schumer from new york thank you mr
chairman and just two procedural points
uh before we begin
one is that last night we were told it'd
only be one opening statement so i
being the shy person that i am prepared
mine and i'll speak for both miss
thurman and myself uh
it's a joke attempted rye attempt at
humor um
or a poor attempt at humor i guess but
in any case so i'll be giving the
opening statement for both of us
second
we did have a snafu with the witnesses
we awoke this morning to find that
one of the witnesses we had requested
who was coming from aberdeen labs the
army's expert on cs gas was last night
unilaterally told by the majority by a
majority staffer that he was not on this
morning's panel he will be on tomorrow
morning's panel but we had wanted him on
both panels
we talked it over with the majority and
came to a uh
decision that rather than hold up the
hearings we would contact that witness
immediately he's at the aberdeen testing
ground which is about 100 miles from
here and he will join us part of the way
through
um
this was we believe this was simply a
mistake by the majority and no nefarious
conspiratorial attempt to deprive us of
our god-given rights uh
you notice though the the
since the beginning and the end the
constructive cooperation on both sides
right here we'll bring this thing
together well i was going to say that
was the nice part of my opening
statement uh
now let me get to the points that i
would like to
make
i guess there are a couple of points
that are beginning to emerge as these
hearings unfold and i'd like to
stress a couple of them
one is i am very concerned
with something that many of the
critiques
on the right about modern america
society uh that i've had some sympathy
with uh seem to be it seems to be
happening here too there's something
called moral relativism which says
there's no right and wrong about
anything
that there are just couple of theories
out there and let's weigh them all some
paul johnson who's a conservative uh
writer and professor says this began
with albert einstein in the theory of
relativity
but in any case i see this exhibited at
this in these hearings in a way that i
find disconcerting
last night was a classic example now
by hypothesis you know we could have a
panel on is the world round or is the
world flat and we could probably find a
couple of people who say the world is
flat and then we'd have some expert
geographers who say the world is round
and the way things work in modern
america the next everyone on television
would just see
some people saying the world is flat and
some people saying the world is round
and the next day all the media would say
well joe smith said it was flat but john
doe rebutted and said it was round and
it would be left there because nobody
draws any conclusions i found that to be
the case a bit in last night's panel
we had two of the world's experts on cs
gas
they testified tear gas cs tear gas is
what i am attempting to call it because
cs gas has sort of a nefarious ring to
it and this is the mildest form of tear
gas available and it's called cs gas or
cs tear gas anyway we had two of the
world's experts
who have spent their lives studying this
issue they come from britain
and they said unequivocally
that the gas was not harmful the way it
was used for children
and in fact if you look at the autopsy
reports those horrible reports of the
chil of everyone who died there's not a
trace found of this gas on any of them
they died in many ways all the people at
waco
many of the adults were shot by bullets
many died by asphyxiation which could
have occurred by fire or other kinds of
things in any case these experts
testified to that extent
then we had two other people
one was a professor of chemistry at a
two-year college in eastern utah who has
done no papers has no expertise
on
this kind of gas
the other was an employee in the
drinking water section of epa
who
also had no expertise and they of course
painted more dramatic and dire pictures
about what the gas is like
well i don't put the four witnesses and
then there was a fifth witness who's a
very credible witness dr stone he's not
an expert on cs gas and he said some
troubling things
which i think we're all going to have to
weigh but the four witnesses who were
experts on the gas
were not comparable at all
and it seemed to me
that
that has happened time and time again
we've had two lawyers who were never on
the site
who were lawyers who were representing
david koresh who said the bullets were
fired first by
um
the
atf uh by them examining a door that is
now missing although the other door has
evidence to the contrary and no one's
given any evidence why one door would be
different than the other door
and yet it gets reported there's a
dispute about who fired first we had all
the agents who were there there were
three reporters hardly employees of the
government usually looking for
skepticism about the government all on
the scene who said
that it was clear
that the uh people in the compound fired
first we have the fact which hasn't been
brought out that the second time
there was an attempt to go to the
compound by the fbi it is clear everyone
agrees the fbi didn't fire a single shot
and yet they were met
with a fuselage
fuselage of uh
gunfire that came from within the
compound there are things in dispute
here
there are mistakes that were made
i think that the panel that was the most
devastating for the government was the
one with sarah bin and wojnatsky
and all of those people and it came
clear and this panel is done this
committee has done a service by showing
that the elements that was of surprise
was lost
and
the raid went forward anyway with the
atf now we've known that before but as
i've said time and time again to make it
public in a televised hearing fine
this hearing will make sure that doesn't
happen again i dare say that in any
federal agency
with a large raid like this when
surprise is lost
they won't do it
but then to get into extraneous i mean
to to sort of equate
the two lawyers with all the others on
the scene and say this is in dispute or
the experts on cs gas with two people i
don't know where they came from but they
have as little expertise or almost as
little expertise on the issue of cs gas
tear gas as i do and say this is in
dispute we have to examine this etc
to me something is wrong
and that is why we in the minority have
had trouble with how the panels were set
up
that is why we in the minority have some
dubiousness
about the mission here
not simply to bring out the truth
but
for some
to air theories
that have been widely discredited
that are held by a few
people who believe in conspiracies
against the government
and it fans those flames
and that's not good
so i would ask everybody my colleagues
on both sides of the aisle the people
listening to this out in america the
media in particular
this is serious stuff
and the idea of just saying that
theories that are flimsy have the same
weight
as theories that are backed up by
witness after witness after witness
is a real problem
i would make two other points that's my
most fundamental point
a second point i would make is related
to that and this one may get some people
on some of my colleagues upset but i'm
going to say it
we hear pro we hear everyone professing
we're on the side of law enforcement we
want to help law enforcement and as i
said these hearings can because anyone
who's on the side of law enforcement
doesn't give them a cart launch just as
i believe the sec has been the best
thing that happened to wall street by
keeping them honest
having oversight of law enforcement
agencies by outside groups including
panels like these does the same
but
when you say you're for law enforcement
in your opening
and then you reach for the most
implausible of theories
and and sort of try to blame law
enforcement
i don't think you're really being for
law enforcement
okay
if you really back up law enforcement
you don't say that two defense lawyers
who were not on the scene are more
credible
than 20 law enforcement officers and
several reporters
who were on the scene you don't say that
a professor from eastern utah
in a two-year school who has no
expertise on this
and a rather controversial employee in
the water division of the epa is the
same as the two world experts
what you're doing is giving the benefit
of the doubt
not to law enforcement but against law
enforcement when you do it
if you want to do that fine lots of
people on my side of the aisle have done
that for many years
but it's not fair to say you're for law
enforcement
and then
take every wacky theory and use it as a
club
with which to beat law enforcement over
the head
so mr chairman those are my points um i
appreciate uh the time to give them and
uh hope we'll have an interesting day mr
schumer i'm sure we will and uh i'd like
to like record to show that you had
about an equal amount of time on both
sides here in the opening statements
um i'd now like to introduce the uh the
panel
to my left your right mr larry potts
former assistant director of the fbi
criminal investigations division
next to him is mr anthony betts was the
chief
the unit chief of domestic terrorism at
the federal bureau of investigations and
research cs gas for the fbi
um i'm sorry
let me go back
next to him was mr jeff
jeffrey jamar was the special agent in
charge of
san antonio texas an on-scene fbi
commander at waco
mr dick rogers in the middle
assistant special agent in charge and
the leader of the fbi hostage rescue
team at waco texas
and mr brian sage was the supervisory
senior resident agent austin
uh resident agent
agency and the first fbi hostage
negotiator on the scene at waco welcome
back again today
and um
see and
and uh i guess i already introduced mr
betts um chief uh unit chief of domestic
terrorism at the federal bureau of
investigations and research cs gas for
the fbi uh dr harry salem phd will be
joining the panel when he can get here
as the chief of life sciences department
research and technology
directorate at the u.s army edgewood
research development and engineering
center for the department of defense
gentlemen if you would please stand and
raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear the testimony
you're about to give this oversight
subcommittees the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
thank you please be seated let the
records show that the answers are in the
infirmity
the
chair now recognizes mr schiff from new
mexico for five minutes
thank you mr chairman mr chairman before
asking questions of this panel i'd like
to talk about yesterday's panel with
respect to cs gas
i have to say first that i think the
credentials of some of the witnesses
were understated for example mr marcus
of the environmental protection agency
testified that his phd was based on or
based in part on a study of inhalation
toxicology
second of all it is significant that
when i ask the british experts upon whom
mr schumer said we should place the most
reliance
to their knowledge has the british
government ever
come up with a plan to insert gas into a
building for 48 hours
or has the british government ever come
up with a plan to insert cs gas into a
building where they knew were children
and infants they both said no so i think
it's extremely interesting that the
experts that we're told are the are the
superior experts in this subject can't
cite an example of where their
government did exactly what our
government did in this particular
situation
mr jamar sir i have a couple of
follow-up questions from yesterday if i
may
i want you to know again that every
member of both of these subcommittees of
both parties wishes that there had been
no loss of life at all in that situation
uh and we we hope that these hearings
will at least produce
enough knowledge that that it won't
occur again
but i want to ask you a question based
upon dr stone's testimony because he
mentioned your name specifically said to
ask you
dr stone who was on the attorney
general's review panel
said that if the if the branch davidians
being armed it is said with automatic
weapons including a 50 caliber machine
gun had wanted to kill atf agents for
the sake of killing atf agents that they
could have done so with automatic
weapons they could have literally wiped
out the entire uh group as they were
disembarking from the trucks and so
forth and said to ask you about that
would would you respond please well
i'd heard about that i'm wondering what
the our discussion he called me what two
years ago almost i guess more than two
years ago discuss
his part of the study group he was on
i think the discussion was really um
there's no question that the branch
civilians intend to kill atf's they've
been firing automatic weapons at them
when they approached
uh and throwing hand grenades at them
that's not the question i think the
context of discussion was i think by the
grace of god more atf agents weren't
killed
i think um
maybe maybe if
please let me finish i'm sorry i the i
think one thing probably part of our
discussion was
that
thank goodness there was a cease-fire
thank goodness that as jim cavanaugh
described so graphically yesterday they
were able to get
agents like wounded agents like kenny
king out of there before he died
but i think to infer that
uh that there's something redeeming
about the fact that i didn't kill more
atf agents is ridiculous
you don't agree then with dr stone that
they could have killed more if they had
wanted to that's why i think they could
have killed more without question i
think they killed as many as they could
until it sees fire i think there's any
question about that
is it true that all the agents who died
were on the roof as doctor don't think
so one agent was shot out front and
behind a van and the other one shot
behind the safe both shot right in the
head thank you for clearing that up yes
sir i'd like to ask about your testimony
from yesterday when the issue was
whether the fbi was correct to move and
try to end the siege or should have
waited i believe that you personally
said i would have waited a year if i had
anything to
hang a hook on with that do you remember
remember saying that yes sir
what would it have taken for you to wait
further what what would you have
expected uh
um
as far as let's use the preparation of
the manuscripts an example that we are
preparing to finish we're going to send
the disc out in two hours
uh the steve snyder said i've just
received i'm editing it i may not get it
to you till tomorrow but i am definitely
editing something we've got something
if you if you would believe that time is
running short if you had believed
that if he when he finished the
manuscripts he would have come out would
you have waited and not recommended the
attack
absolutely
well let me ask then
what about the
abuse of the children sexual abuse or
other abuse that was going on
inside the compound in your judgment
i'm i've been told that that was a
reason for advising a a forceful end of
the siege
if that was a reason for ending the
siege why would you have waited for mr
koresh to have finished his manuscripts
if you believed he would really have
come out well i think if if he had to
believe if he was giving me something
such as a manuscript let's get that met
i don't one of the fears i had was that
he was never going to do that and when
he was doing the manuscript then he
would do something provocative however
let's use the children let's say we
asked for a tape of the children to
force them to clean the children if they
weren't already clean show us that
they're nice and healthy show us that if
that would have been the case let's say
if i said wait a year they would have
given us some children
show us that these children are healthy
show us that the inside that the
sanitation and the and the threat of
disease is not what we think it is
demonstrate that to us by sending people
out who were in good health but but just
to conclude
you're now saying that if uh if mr
koresh really in your judgment was going
to come out after writing his manuscript
uh you would have given that additional
time even though previously it's been
said that because of abuse of children
not neglect but of actual sexual assault
and child rape uh we had to move fast
don't isolate to one reason that the the
threat of the children's health the
threat of disease and the fact that we
would could very
easily con infer that his previous abuse
would continue was one factor there were
there were many many factors that was
just one
okay i think i think my time has expired
thank you mr chairman yes sir
um
chair now recognizes mr scott from
virginia
thank you mr chairman we went over some
of this yesterday and i just want to
reiterate mr
betts
what is your position with the fbi
i'm currently the assistant special
agent in charge of the baltimore
division
and do you have any special expertise
in
cs gas
i have operational expertise as a marine
officer a police officer in five years
with the hostage rescue team isn't used
very often
it's quite commonly used in law
enforcement has been
it's been commercially available i
believe since 1958
do you know of any
deaths that have occurred as a direct
result
no sir i don't there is still no
documented death that is unequivocally
attributable to cs now are there other
gases
so-called tear gases
are there alternative gases
yes there are
cn
yes or oc
yes sir cn uh the bureau does not
maintain cnn in the inventory because
there are deaths that can be documented
scientifically attributable to cn what
about oc gas i'm sorry sir oc pepper
spray oh ole resin capsicum
uh
has the safety of that been documented
nothing's been nearly extensively a
study to see us is there any question
amongst experts as to which tear gas is
the safest
there is no question among experts who
i've contacted that cs is by far the
safest and most extensively studied
so if gas were to be used there would be
no
question amongst experts which gas it
ought to be there's been no question
among experts that i've contacted
based on last night i think there'd be
questions depending on your experts now
the
plan to insert the gas and the amount of
gas inserted is there any question
whether or not a
lethal amount of gas was inserted into
the compound
there is no question based on
calculations that i
observed over many hours uh performed by
british scientists given the knowns uh
that uh at
waco that being the volume of the
building
the ventilation and in fact the
ventilation was very much understated
when dr rice in testimony last night
said what really happened was referring
to was we based all our calculations on
low ventilation just to ensure an extra
safety factor in the calculations
but anyone who knows the conditions over
the 51 days
and including that day would know that
in that area of texas there is a steady
wind commonly through the day so low
ventilation was unrealistic but we still
use that
yeah
everybody knows what ended up
happening
at the end
who was involved in the actual decision
mr jamar you were involved in the
decision to go forward
what did you did you expect
what happened
to have happened
no we feared it we didn't expect that
okay now hopefully that that the cs gas
would drive them from the company so you
knew that there was a chance
that
quresh
because of his beliefs might use the
opportunity
to kill everybody yes sir
what you knew that was a possibility we
feared that yes sir
um
what weight was given to that
possibility
tremendous weight and that was why it
would uh we took so long to come to that
decision but there was the other side
as we discussed yesterday is that
do we let him determine
when he was going to do it and what
measures could we take such as two
o'clock in the morning as a breakout
with the child intervention or by firing
or starting a fire or whatever it might
be
what measures could we take at that time
when we're not prepared what idea was to
try to do this in the safest manner was
to do it where we were best prepared and
we you know with the medical care and
everything we had available there
and
the theory on the gas is that we would
do it incrementally
and make the place uninhabitable the
thought that people would be breathing
gas for 48 hours is not correct ideally
they would move away from the from
from
the areas where gas well what are the
chances what chance
did you give to the possibility that
they might
die as a result of what you did as
they might be rescued as a result of
what you did
well i think the we wouldn't have done
if we if we didn't think that the odds
of their being rescued outweighed
the fear of
mass murder or suicide
what we're trying to do is preempt his
his being courage
deciding when it was going to happen
what he did he decided was going to
happen on april 19th
but i am firmly convinced that
ultimately he was gonna that end would
be there
but we thought our opportunity to save
lives was best if we dictated when
an action was taken not courage
thank you
chair now recognize mr satter five
minutes
i wanted to say for the record that i'm
getting tired of mr schumer questioning
uh to the point of smearing us about our
commitment to law enforcement mr
heinemann was chief of police in raleigh
mr bryant was a u.s attorney in
tennessee mr schadeg was an assistant
attorney general in arizona mr barr was
a u.s attorney in georgia
i have never been a defense attorney in
my life in fact i write in my campaign
that i'm not an attorney
i've always been
committed to law enforcement we are
trying to ask questions i'm sorry if in
the process of asking questions which
happens in the rodney king case and
others that in fact sometimes sets back
law enforcement because there's so much
focus as you're trying to sort through
the different process but it isn't going
to intimidate me from trying to get to
that point and i hope you realize that
it is not helpful to those of us who've
been long committed
to it to our support for to be
constantly accused because we're trying
to do our job in oversight
mr
betts i wanted to ask you some questions
understanding that you're predominantly
a tactical cs expert and not a
scientific you can perhaps at least
answer for me
and explain uh
if you didn't directly who would have
directly and what went uh to the
people who made the decision regarding
the gas of what
did you take into consideration of the
dangers of gassing children was it that
it's okay to guess them that no evidence
exists that showing it's dangerous or
that in fact evidence exists that shows
that it isn't dangerous what what was
the discussion around the gassing of
children and how was that debated
internally yes sir the discussions i had
were primarily with dr harry salem from
the u.s current
u.s army chemical research development
and education center edgewood maryland
which is the singular
center to the best of my knowledge in
the united states for expertise in that
area and children were very heavily
discussed and i read
attempted read every paper dr salem gave
me and he certainly read
i believe he queried almost 500
individual research reports
in those reports
including the hemsworth report that was
mentioned last night there were
references to children who had been
exposed
in great britain those children who were
exposed in enclosed areas recovered upon
exposure to air
in the instance that was mentioned last
night which is the parking giamona study
in 1972 in california oh
sorry um
i'm also familiar with that report
and
that child was admitted to the hospital
and recovered with antibiotics
in 28 days
and that was in all the research that's
been cited including by dr stone that
was the only instance
of a child
being admitted to the hospital that i'm
aware of
in
is a standard operating procedure as
you're inserting the gas
gradually to do it over several days
that would actually add quite a safety
factor to inserting gas in any situation
as you discussed
in your briefing that you might sharply
accelerate that process if the tank was
fired upon
uh what i'm familiar with is that there
was a also a backup plan that if the
tanks were fired upon there was an
alternative plan to utilize ferret
rounds
in addition to the insertion point and
did
did the discussion when you were talking
about the impact of gas on the children
calculate that if you accelerated the
process that it would potentially have
more impact and also could you talk a
little bit about did you discuss the
disorienting
impact on the parents and their children
as to whether they'd be able to see and
get nauseous be able to find their way
out yes sir
that was discussed very much and i
questioned dr salem on that myself and i
went over the most common
effects of cs and there is an effect
that causes you to blink extensively but
the the most common effects and the
effects that are that it's intended to
have are sensory irritant effects which
is what we desired there's no effect
there that i'm aware of that would cause
someone to not be able to
escape the environment which is actually
the intention mr jamar i was really
interested yesterday i think you said
seven of the nine people who did in fact
come out i either came out through one
of the halls or were directly rescued
does that suggest did anybody come out
through the routes that you thought they
were going to come out
that looked like to me compelled by the
gas
tear gas i didn't i didn't see that
but i don't know
of the nine whether how much gas they
were that they touched i don't know that
but my question is is that because the
walls were knocked down you said that's
how many of them got out does that
suggest that they couldn't find their
way out otherwise
no the point there was that the front
door
i think the context of the question was
why did you knock holes in the walls
that was the context
was that the doors blocked the door that
was the front door that we that they
used all the time we discovered by
trying to open it we were wondering why
aren't anybody why aren't any people
coming out
so we
had one of the cevs push the door and we
discovered it was blockaded so we made a
another door
uh we couldn't see at the back there
were doors out the back and we could
never get in there by the pool and
the pictures here but you know what you
remember when i'm talking about the
swimming pools we're afraid to go in
there because the concrete was so weak
and the tank the the heavy weight of the
tank would maybe fall down in there
we made a hole around the back
gentleman's time is expired mr conyers
five minutes
gentlemen just one word
an observance of the nature of these
hearings across
this week
no one
on either of these two committees
has been a more forceful critic
of law enforcement than myself
i've been doing it more often and longer
than anyone on the committee
i
talked to secretary rubin and under
secretary noble about the old boys
roundup and the environment in atm
which is more important than the event
itself that leads to these things being
summarily happening
i've talked to three or four
fbi directors in the course of my career
about the discrimination in employment
i've been talking to
mrs meisner in immigration and
naturalization service about the longest
outstanding and largest class action
suit
that african-american agents have
brought against any
federal agency in history and we're
trying to
take care of that
i go back and us attorneys to attorney
or attorney generals to levy and others
i'm shocked that the department of
justice would try to weaken the
exclusionary rule i've opposed u.s
attorneys
who try to run their
trials by press release
intimidating defense witnesses and
people brought before
the criminal justice
system but waco has to stand
in an examination on its own merit
that's the subject that brings us here
today
and uh i think that
that the
whole event now has been made clear
uh here was the most massive assault on
law enforcement that's ever been
unleashed taken by surprise
pulling up all that weaponry
and
firepower did not intimidate
a
correction the davidians one bit
and and it's out of that tragedy and the
strategies that bring us here today and
and the question of gas
and i'd like to ask you mr sage in the
transcripts
where you were
in fact
helping they were recorded with your
comments and other unidentified people
inside
there was some suggestion that all of
the references
to
do you you want it poured
uh
it's poured already
should we light the package now yeah
okay light it
you got to put the fuel in there too
this was casually
dismissed
total hearsay
by lawyers that were admitting they were
represented
representing koresh
but this was referring to pouring gas in
molotov cocktails
uh can you help us clear that up
it's i believe the clear
uh
indication from a reading of the
transcript would indicate that uh that
it was not
at least it's clear to me that they were
preparing that uh that compound for
uh an apocalyptic end unfortunately that
certainly was not iron town
were there any molotov cocktails thrown
not that i'm aware of
did you did you know about any inside
the compound
no sir not until uh after assessment of
the uh
of the record here
and and finally uh
in terms of the
strategy on the gas
uh i think it was
mr
maybe dick rogers there was initial plan
to have the gradual insertion of gas but
at some point it was determined
that it should be uh introduced
excuse me
uh in larger quantities can you help us
get some understanding of that
strategy there or the change of strategy
that may have occurred
yes sir that was not really a change in
strategy we had factored in
a contingency that
should
our vehicle be met with gunfire
when it went up to make the initial
insertion
and the only thing we could do is to
respond with additional
ferret rounds of tear gas
in order to try to reduce the fire
coming towards our vehicles
everyone has made the assumption that
because
we had military armored vehicles
that the agents inside were completely
safe and that's just not true
in order to fire those ferret rounds
there were openings in the sides of
those uh bradley fighting vehicles
that we had actually enlarged from what
their original design was for the
military what was the purpose for that
well the purpose was so that our agents
could uh
uh be able to aim their uh
their 40 millimeter gas guns through the
openings and be able to accurately put
those ferret rounds into their uh into
their targets
if you can shoot out you can also shoot
in and that was our concern with the
safety of our people in there if a round
came into that bradley it's going to
ricochet around inside that armored
vehicle
and clearly we're going to have
casualties among the fbi agents
so when they started uh opening fire
with automatic weapons we saw green
tracers coming out of that building then
we went to uh what we call a compromise
plan which was to
go ahead and put ferrets in all those
openings to to insert more gas rather
than insert more gas
they they forced us basically to back
off of this very phased very carefully
thought out
plan to deny portions of that building
over a period of 48 hours and had they
not opened fire you would have had a
gradual insertion of the gas yes sir and
let me also clear up one thing the plan
was never to insert gas for 48 hours the
plan was to insert gas over a period of
48 hours which is a big difference
to talk about just in concluding mr
chairman what what is the difference
there well the difference is we only
we're only going to put so much gas into
the building
all of the calculations that
the experts have used
is based on putting gas into a place and
measuring its effect within a one minute
period we're talking about 48 hours that
we're going to continue this operation
huge difference
if you take into account the wind that
we had there blowing across that plane
in texas
my personal opinion is that gas had very
little if any effect on anyone inside i
think it was quickly ventilated as soon
as we put it in there
thank you very much and thank you mr
chairman
thank you
mr bryant
five minutes
thank you mr chairman i have a number of
questions and if you could keep your
answers as short as possible uh mr jamar
did i i was kind of cut off on my time
last night but did i understand you
testified yesterday that the president
of the united states was aware of this
uh siege basically siege plan
but wanted to know of any change i
wanted to be made aware of any change in
that strategy
was that in your notes yes sir okay and
i assume that you assumed uh by briefing
justice and the fbi that the president
it wasn't your job to call the president
tell them you were fixing going with
tanks but you assumed that the other
folks your superiors would do that
the uh we're talking about two different
times uh mr brian i i think at the
beginning i was told
that
the president said it
that don't do anything beyond
negotiation without going back to him
unless there's emergency okay and there
was never an emergency
there was never an emergency was there
from during the period no one didn't
have one that would that would make us
depart from that not an officer now i
would interpret that to mean that he
wanted to know in the future he didn't
have you know he didn't limit that to a
week or whatever he just said if unless
it's a change well i think one of the
changes that occurred was by mark i
think march 12th we have an attorney
general now it wasn't remember
the normal
hierarchy of a of an administration was
didn't exist
when when on february 28th
acting attorney general mr gerson and
you had uh the transition team mr hubble
leading that who was mr clinton's well
that's that's my point is sir that that
had everyone been in place
we wouldn't have been told the president
we have been told the attorney general
said this there's a huge difference in
my mind but you're not saying the
president was dealing directly with you
i'm sorry
my point is
in the normal times like today
something like that occurred and there
were special instructions from from the
attorney general or from the president
would be to the attorney general and it
would be reported to me that the
attorney general said do this okay let
me let me move on good and i've got
another question for you mr jamar uh ms
sparks from the texas human services
department testified that she had been
asked by the fbi to plan a contingency
plan
uh for showers and and stuff to clean
these children after they were gassed
and that right before this occurred uh
this was canceled do you know why she
was
this idea of having uh medical aid and
showers for children no the
decontamination of everyone coming out
was was there it was stayed in place
they were the survivors were
decontaminated by by fbi no by
biomedical personnel okay but the texas
people were not using it that was my
point she left the impression with me
that this contingency plan had just been
cancelled at least as far as her that's
not correct
okay thank you
mr potts uh
did you play a role in the formation of
this plan that that included the gas
insertion yes sir i did okay
and uh do you what information and i
guess and how frequently did you pass on
uh
this information to the department of
justice
that's that's not an easy question to
answer in short term i mean when in
terms of formation of the gas plan i
think that mr jamar first contacted me
probably around march 27th or some
somewhere near the very end of march
uh to indicate that such a plan was was
being submitted
there were extensive internal
discussions that went on
for a period of uh
of a couple of weeks okay now let me let
me move on internal to the fbi
uh
was april the 12th the first time that
justice main justice knew about this
plan that included the gas insertion i'm
not sure
i'm sorry i i'm not sure that april 12
was the first time they knew it was the
first time that we had had briefed them
i believe that they knew
as a result of a visit that floyd clark
the deputy director and i had made
to waco
on the 7th and 8th
that discussions were being held
regarding
uh possible insertion of who was who was
they injustice knew this oh i'm sorry
well i think that first of all i think
there was mark richard
uh there was uh
mr reynolds jim reynolds
uh there was um mr hubble
uh and eventually the attorney general
probably knew as of uh the ninth
that there were discussions going on
with the within the fbi
and we had asked then the director
director sessions at the time
had asked on the 9th of april for a
meeting with the attorney general on the
12th
to brief her on what our plan was thank
you very much
i believe my time is up
ms
collins thank you mr chairman i yield 30
seconds to the gentleman from virginia
mr scott thank you mr chairman mr jamar
and the responsible last question you
indicated that you knew that there was a
real chance that their
loss of life might occur
but you believed that the catastrophic
ending would eventually occur
sometime
based on his conduct
i would trust that you would have more
than just speculation to justify your
action and have a solid foundation for
your belief that the risk of loss was
justified i'm going to just pose the
question i don't want to take any more
of mrs collins time but as you answer
the other questions i'd be very
interested in what kind of foundation
you had for that belief to justify the
loss of life and i thank the lady from
illinois for yielding thank you
yesterday we heard from yet another
witness dr alan stone that
representatives of the national rifle
association contacted him posing as a
staff member of this committee the
chairman of the government reform
committee has declined my repeated
request that we called individuals to
testify as to their activities which may
have interfered with these hearings
as a member of congress i fully believe
that we have an obligation to ensure
that allegations of unethical or illegal
activity are investigated particularly
when they affect a congressional hearing
because the chairman has not responded
to my last request to pursue these
allegations i intend to forward this
information to the united states
attorney for the district of columbia
for review for possible criminal
violations because i think it's
extremely important that we do so
i um
let me say this too
i'm concerned about the decision to use
gas on the compound not because i
believe that if the correctness
followers were coming out on their own
but because there were children in the
compound anytime children are exposed or
to be exposed to a chemical such as tear
gas i certainly want to know about it
the thing that concerns me the most
about this however is that there has
been conflicting
issues here
so the issue that needs to be addressed
is the alternatives that were available
to the fbi
first would the children have been safer
staying in the compound while other
options were pursued or was exposure to
gas the safest option i'm going to ask
everyone to answer that one
is jamar
as i tried to
describe earlier
the
concern we had was that starting in
around
the 24th 25th of march there that
we thought that
negotiations were an impasse
that there's no indication of any thing
at that time in the short term changing
anything
that he would that he would begin to let
people come out or he would change his
attitude in any way
so he said what are our options what
options do we have
to prevent him from
causing the deaths of those people
inside
law enforcement has very limited options
uh
that are non-lethal
we never contemplated
uh assaulting a compound to make an
entry absent
indication that he was systematically
killing people inside there we never
contemplate except in those
circumstances
the options left to law enforcement are
limited to
insertion of cs gas that's just about it
so we started discussing well
if he decides on his terms that he wants
to destroy those people inside how would
we stop him we would stop him with cs
gas so we said well to keep him from
doing that on his terms and his
timetable then
maybe the best thing to do is
to
try to preempt that by driving the
people from the compound by the use of
cs gas
attorney general reno made the decision
to allow the insertion of cs tear gas
only after meeting with a number of
experts outside the department of
justice and one of those was dr harry
salem who was an expert on the use of
tear gas for the department of defense
and the witness who was scheduled for
this council so i'd like to ask mr
rogers about that meeting and i want to
know what the questions were that the
attorney general asked about the use of
the gas against the children what advice
dr salem and the other members of the
meeting gave her please
yes ma'am i was at that meeting
attorney general reno quizzed dr salem
very extensively
she was
extremely concerned about the children
she asked a number of probing questions
of the doctor
he responded that
and i don't want to speak for him but my
memory of that that meeting was that uh
basically there there had never been a
documented case of a child or anyone
else dying from cs tear gas
that uh the military had done ex
extensive testing on it
and basically he allayed her fears that
the cs tear gas was uh toxic or that
would kill anyone inside that compound
particularly in the
amounts that we anticipated putting in
there
so
my impression in walking away from that
meeting was that
she was satisfied with the answers she
got from the doctor and that
we had reached out to
what we thought was the very best
opinion and legal expert i mean not a
legal expert scientific expert in this
area in the united states and he had
provided those answers to her
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you
chief heinemann
five minutes
thank you mr chairman
mr potts
on
february the 28th what was your
position in the hierarchy
i was the assistant director of the
criminal investigative division at fbi
headquarters
were you
mr jamal's
direct connect
with them with the hierarchy yes sir i
was and who were you responsible too i
reported to doug gao who was the
associate deputy director
and
as per yesterday's testimony mr jamaat
said he spoke to you frequently
as to the situation in waco yes sir
i just wanted to
i was cut off by the red light yesterday
at mr jamaa's level
mr jamar i spoke to you yesterday and
asked you about the siege situation
as to whether you considered that a
hostage situation
yes sir and your response to me was
no you considered that a barricaded
criminal situation yes
and certainly it was there were
barricaded criminals in there
um
mr rogers and i would ask gary nesner if
he was here
do you have a
a protocol
for
for
barricaded situations where there are
children involved
at that time
we don't we do not have
written protocols that you go to
um and i'm not trying to be flipped but
as a recipe book
where you pick a particular situation
and you flip to it and we've got written
contingency plans specifically
everything i've been involved in in 25
years in the fbi
is almost unique in itself
every uh every hostage barricade
situation is different that a lot of
variables a lot of variables a lot of
different
generally different people different
situations uh
and it's all variable well i realize you
have to
as they say
go by the city of pants at a lot of
these
situations because of variables
um well and certainly and certainly
we're looking to improve the process yes
sir i wouldn't classify it as seat of
our pants i mean we we have uh
very extensive training of our uh
personnel we have uh very uh
good intelligence staff and when we make
a decision it's not a seat of the pants
uh decision well you have to make the
decision based on the variables
and the facts at hand right sir
um and hopefully
hopefully
based on what we've learned here
yesterday and
what will what we'll talk about the next
couple of days the the use of cs gas and
any other uh type ordnance as it relates
to the children
i hope that
i hope that
that your section of the the fbi the the
training section
has taken everything i will take
everything that's mentioned at these
hearings into consideration
and develop some kind of a
a greater sensitivity to
infants now
certainly you don't know how cs gas
affects children i think there was
testimony
last night amongst the phds that none of
them knew how cs gas would affect
a child and the two but i think that's
something we need to
seriously think about in light of what's
happened i don't know how it affects
children
so i was in no better position to
to judge that then
mr jamar or mr patrick's superiors but i
would like to think we could leave here
with the lesson learned to give great
consideration even if it's
experiment not experimentation but but
further study into the effective
ordinance on
on even
small children and i'll yield the
balance of my time to mr saban
you seemed it seemed pretty predictable
they were going to fire in the tanks and
didn't it seemed predictable also they
were going to barricade the door was
that the primary place you thought they
were going to come out
well the
the
if they believed we were going to try to
enter the compound and i and the way the
the uh over here sounded like there was
one comment we're going to wait until
they come in
before we light this
there was a comment during on the over i
don't think they had the door barricaded
because they wanted us to come in
did you think the idea was to keep
people from going out not to keep us
from going man just to keep people that
was fairly predictable even some it did
didn't you i don't think it's
necessarily predictable i'm just saying
it's easy to conclude that after the
fact
well we have all kinds of things that
you know i'm talking about maybe there
are other doors too but i'm i'm thinking
that
get back to your first thing about them
firing on i believed
it was 99 when we approached the tank
they would fire i believe that not all
people agree with me on that but i
believe that at the time yes thanks
gentlemen's time has inspired sheila
jackson lee texas
mr chairman thank you very much and good
morning to the gentlemen that are there
with us this morning
let me make a couple of remarks before i
ask
maybe two very abbreviated questions
i hope as we continue to unfold the
facts
in these proceedings and we're now
almost to an end
we can keep before us
two
procedural prongs of the fork
that is that we are fact finders
bringing to the table whether they're
witnesses or whether we are congress
persons our own biases and insight and
review
the second point is that we owe a
responsibility to the american people to
be problem solvers
and that the only way we can do so is to
probe your minds and to try to
understand what went on we were not
there
we've heard a
discourse of disparate voices about
who's believing what or what side of the
aisle is more pro-law enforcement or not
interestingly the irony of voices from
the american public maybe people who
would have said completely different
things if we were having a hearing on
the nra
are now making strange accusations
because they think people are biased
but if we can keep before us those two
problems facts as best we can with human
frailties
and then to resolve it i hope you will
give me your true and honest answer
you're obviously sworn in you're
obviously law enforcement officers so
that we can keep that before us and as
well
make good of these proceedings
which i believe have started in the best
interest of the american public
but i would simply say to you that
those of us who've been accused one way
or the other can say certain points
about law enforcement
did i agree with cointelpro that
permeated the civil rights movement some
years ago no
was i skeptical about the onslaught of
law enforcement in the peace movement
student peace movement i raised my voice
of opposition
was i satisfied that the black panthers
were truly conspirators to undermine the
government no
uh and so i raised my voice and concern
of that
or the worst of all evidence by local
police in the filmed version of what
happened to rodney king did we raise our
voices against that yes we did
and i'm certainly against in local
communities young black men being
arrested for walking on the wrong side
of the street
however i think we need to be balanced
and so
i think it's important
that we acknowledge
the efforts that have been made
when young freedom riders rode into the
deep south that they had to rely upon
federal law enforcement to protect their
rights carrying forth the bill of rights
and the constitution
i think we have to realize when bright
african-american students tried to enter
universities in the deep south federal
law enforcement had to provide that
safety net
i think we also need to acknowledge when
a very vital voice to our entire
community this nation was silenced by
deadly force dr martin luther king
we didn't know whether this nation would
be able to withstand that blow
along with the assassinations of
president john f kennedy
assassination of bobby kennedy and yes
the attack on ronald reagan federal law
enforcement had to take its role
so i think when we begin to look at this
issue let us balance the good and the
bad
and my question that i'd like all of you
to answer two-fold again
on the cns gas
was the effort to provide an opportunity
for those children and those women and
those men to come out tell me the plan
and then two
why
did you not wait
taxpayers dollars or not
why did you not wait mr potts and i'd
like all of the witnesses to answer
those questions please
first of all
cs gas was was was chosen because
we believe it to be the the absolute
least
harmful of any
of of gas that it would not be harmful
to the children that it would not be
harmful to people in there but it would
drive them out of the house
i want you have to understand that
when this plan was first formulated and
we talked about the impact on the
children we went to experts to find out
how will this impact on the kids
and even after finding out from the
experts that they didn't believe the cs
gas
would be harmful to the children
we then put in certain other aspects in
the plan which would build in extra
safety
aspects for the kids
for instance
there was a very
active discussion when mr clark and i
went to waco to talk about how this plan
was was going to go about
dick rogers of hrt was very concerned as
you just heard about the safety of his
people
being fired upon if if they started
firing from inside the compound his
people were going to be very much
exposed to that
they
would if they would have had the perfect
plan for them in order of safety for the
hrt agents it would not have included an
advanced warning
because that just gives people a chance
to get their weapons to aim and to be
ready
and you might have to aim back and shoot
and kill that's right that's right and
and so
the advanced warning was something that
we talked about an awful lot as to
whether how how much safety are we
giving up for the agents
but we did that advanced warning because
we wanted to make sure that they knew
what we were doing
and to give them a chance to get the
children
and bring them out of the compound
now if you say why why should they take
them out of the compound at that point
what if they said we're not going to
leave this compound the other thing that
we we talked about and discussed
was that during a
several hour fire fight that you heard
described so graphically the other day
by mr kavanaugh
during that entire firefight
not a single
child was harmed
all those bullets that were going back
and forth and not one child was harmed
where were the children during the fire
fight children were probably in some
place that was safe
you given them advance warning they can
either bring them out of the compound or
they can put the children somewhere
that's safe
that was another safety aspect that we
thought about that would give them a
chance to
to
to save
the children from any exposure
the third aspect of that plan that i
think was built around
safety to the children and not safety to
our agents
safety to our agents the best would have
been to put all the gas in at one time
the military advised us that hrt advised
us of that and several of the sacs on
site
absolutely demanded that it all be put
in at one time for the safety of our
agents you're going to get an agent
killed if you try to do this thing
incrementally
but again for the safety of those people
inside and particularly for the safety
of the children we decided that what we
wanted to do
was not try to bring this thing to an
end on april 19th
april 19th was not any kind of a d day
where we said we've got to end this
thing right now
april 19th was to put some gas in one
portion
of that compound
and then back away
they can go to another part of the
compound they can go to another place
that doesn't have gas but what it does
is hopefully
begin to limit the area of that compound
that they have access to
and at the same time provide an
opportunity for some of those people who
are inside to come out
an excellent chance for that to occur
the rules of engagement
during the operation itself and i'm i'm
sorry i'm going on but all of this i
think is important for the children
the rules of engagement when we started
to put the gas in
the attorney general talked to the
director and deployed clark and everyone
else and said
i want special rules of engagement to
make sure that we go out of our way not
to gas the children
so if you see a child
in one particular area where you were
going to put gas in
don't put gas in that area you don't
have to stop the gassing operation but
move to another area of the compound
if you see a child being threatened
or if they say if you put any more gas
in this compound the children are going
to die or we're going to kill the
children any indication about danger or
harm to those children the rule was back
off
get away stop
our hopes were to gas part of that
compound move them to another part of
that compound and move negotiations
along
if not a single person came out
if it made david koresh begin to
to negotiate with us again in earnest
and stop trying to manipulate everyone
we thought that it would be a success
every one of those things was for the
safety of the children and to limit what
mr jamar talks about
you know i wanted to make sure
he said he said i thought that maybe
they were going to fire there's a good
likelihood they were going to fire on
our tanks we did everything we could
to limit that possibility
because of the way that we had done this
entire operation
every time we got ready to go up to the
compound with a tank we told them we
were going up to the compound with the
tank if we were going to move cars we
told them we were going to move cars
when we got to that last piece of fence
in front of the compound most of the
people said
they're going to fire on you
if you try to move that fence
we moved that last piece of fence on the
18th and no one fired
in fact there was very limited reaction
on the inside except when we moved david
crush's
camaro
when we moved his car he became very
upset but not defense
we bumped up against that compound with
a cev just days before the gassing
operation and there was no violent
response
because everything we did we told them
what we were going to do in advance and
we were honest with them
we were honest with them that morning we
gave them an advance warning
we then we moved up with only one
tank to insert gas in one section
and regretfully they fired on us
immediately
our response rather than firing back was
to put gas
to try to suppress the fire and protect
our agents
let me just interrupt for a second
sheila jackson lee i appreciate your
your
intent here uh before this gets out of
hand i just want to ask you if you could
the idea is to ask a question if you're
in the middle of a question red light
goes on we don't want 15 minutes to
ensue and if you can try to keep the
question in such a way and the answers
in such a way that we can keep within
the integrity of the five minutes we go
over a little bit but we don't want to
go over 10 15 20 minutes chairman i
appreciate your kindness i'd like the
other gentleman to be able to give their
answers that's fair i just want to make
the point that we're trying to keep the
intent of the five-minute rule and mr
chairman uh in keeping with that i'd
like the other gentleman to be reminded
of my answer of my question rather of
why you did not wait and i did hear part
of that mr potts thank you mr pond
uh mr post gave a very comprehensive
answer i would i was nothing i would add
to it is that
part of the plan and discussion we had
was another thing we didn't want to do
is to indicate to course that we're
there to fill part of his prophecy by
entering the compound
so we kept
we had the concertina wire around we
kept the bradley vehicles outside the
wire they could clearly see because it's
lighted they could clearly see
the
valleys were not going to come inside
the wire they could see that only one
vehicle approached the compound
that's not an indicator of a bunch of
people coming in it's only his own tank
doesn't hold that many people there
weren't anybody it wasn't anybody around
the tank
just the one approaching and we told
them what was going to happen
this tank's going to come up it's going
to insert gas
at the time just come on out
we can discuss this
you know communicate with us
so that was part of that with the safety
concerns but also to communicate to the
compound we are not entering the
compound we're not fulfilling this
prophecy don't presume that
the reason we didn't wait was
the thing i've tried to say several
times i'm not saying it well enough is
that if we what if
from his actions on the 19th when he
made the when he had some of those
people killed when he and by gunfire
others died in the fire
not being able to leave which i think
they were concerned over most of their
salvation that's that was his hold over
him
is that
he would dictate when that occurred but
his actions is we were hopeful he would
not kill all those people but his
actions on the 19th convinced me that
that was his plan all along
i always thought he'd try to survive
himself and then everybody else would be
dead he'd come out that's how much i
think he cared about himself
but by his actions on the 19th we were
we feared mass suicide but we thought
we could prevent it by the with the gas
so but
i i still thought there was a chance i
wouldn't have done it if i thought it'd
be suicide but i the other thing is if
we waited he would do it on his
timetable that's why we didn't wait any
further if there'd been one thing
miss jackson lee that would indicate to
us of a change in attitude
the smallest thing that's why we kept
staying for another week
you know he'd tell us when we tried
again which we you know we tried and
tried and tried so
the the reason we didn't wait any longer
was if
he would he would decide when it would
happen
and
i think the the other point i want to on
the gas is we would not have gone with
cs gas if there was any indication to us
that would permanently harm those
children
mrs jackson i think that
maybe i need to give you a little better
understanding of my feeling as to why we
needed to initiate something
as opposed to just continuing with the
status quo we looked at the options what
could we have done other than continue
with the waiting
well one thing we could have built a
wall or put wire around that compound as
some people have suggested and i think
that uh
that doesn't take much explanation to
understand that's totally unacceptable
and let's just pull back
we could have
done a nighttime assault
where we actually had to send agents in
um
we calculated that there would be loss
of life to both our fbi agents
and most likely to davidians perhaps
some children if we had to
take that approach which some people
have suggested
and i've been faulted for by the way for
not for not doing that
and we could have been inserted
non-lethal
cs tear gas which
in my experience has been more or less
the standard by which
law enforcement
standard tool which they use to end a
barricaded situation
the other reason is that by continuing
with this waiting and having david
korish initiate something
i only had between a third to a half of
my resources physically around the
compound at any one time
for example
i would normally keep one or two
physicians there in the medical triage
area
on the morning of the 19th i had 12
physicians there
we had probably the largest law
enforcement medical contingency set up
near that compound that's ever existed
over 13 paramedics
we had airlift capability with three
chinooks
where we could take out 35 people at one
time to hospitals we had the entire
hospital
uh network within that part of texas
alerted the waiting room set up in case
there was an explosion or there was some
kind of suicide so massive preparations
had gone into ensuring
that if something were to happen
that we would be able to handle it and
try to reduce the loss of life
if he were to come out at two in the
morning we wouldn't have had those
things there
so that's the reason that in my opinion
we needed to go forward
and try to move on this contrary to what
you've heard
when i heard that david korish was
coming out quote unquote after he
translated the seven seals in my opinion
he was never coming out
instead of being hopeful
to me that was that was the final straw
that he has no intentions of coming out
because we had lived with every promise
that he had broken for over seven weeks
your other question was about
openings for people to get out of
when we inserted that gas around 602 in
the morning
they didn't know the gas was coming
we do not believe that that front door
was blocked at that time i think that
front door was blocked later in the
morning we saw the front door open it
several times during that morning and we
knew it wasn't uh blocked except
later in the morning sometime after 10
30 when we went ahead and opened it up
but we had planned to make openings in
that building for escape
if there were people in there who were
being held against their will
we wanted them to have the physical
ability to get out of that compound
so that was factored into our planning
all along
you mentioned a need for accountability
i think everybody that's here has been
here uh welcomes this opportunity
frankly
i'll trade and try to make my responses
brief because of concerns for time
two questions effort and why we didn't
wait
from a negotiation standpoint
i've never been involved in a situation
where so much effort was brought to bear
so much effort was so thoroughly
explored uh every viable option that was
presented to us and i stress the word
viable was pursued
we did not turn away anything that could
have led to a peaceful surrender of
those individuals and extraction of all
of them not just the kids all of them
but certainly the kids is a top priority
why didn't we wait
we've heard several times here that we
waited for 51 days
a key thing to remember in the mindset
of all of us that last day
was that we had not had a child
our top priority we had not had a child
exit that compound in 45 days
45 days
we had not had a branch davidian exit
that compound in 32 days
which is probably
i i was gonna well it was probably 32
times longer than most sieges would last
this was an extraordinary situation i
hope it doesn't become a precedent
setting situation for the time spent
cs gas the introduction of the cs gas
from a negotiation standpoint did not
herald the end of negotiations
i mentioned this yesterday we intended
to continue to negotiate with david or
steve or anyone in there that was
willing to talk to us and facilitate a
safe and orderly exit
the last thing i'd like to say is that
uh
it was never my understanding and i
don't think it's uh it was our
understanding collectively to expose
these children or anyone else for an ex
for an extended period of time the
intention of sending in the cs gas which
was embraced
by the negotiation team on the 22nd of
march
was to initiate or to prompt
a rapid exit from that compound not to
prolong
anybody's agony or exposure and i've
i've been in that situation as i
mentioned yesterday i would have been
out in a new york minute
yes
i wasn't involved in any meetings or
decisions concerning weight or don't
wait so i have to limit myself to what
was provided to leadership as far as
factors would be and that would be
concerning cs
and the expert advice that was provided
and that i was shown clearly
was that it would be virtually
impossible outside of an ideal
laboratory situation to insert enough cs
to create risk
and that's that's the bottom line on the
invite on the advice was provided and
given the conditions at waco
it would have been several times removed
from
or maybe hundreds of times removed from
that laboratory condition
so to even attain a risk factor
by at least a couple of research studies
was virtually unattainable outside that
environment and that's the kind of
advice that was provided to our leaders
i thank the gentleman and mr chairman i
yield back the balance of my time
i just uh i just like to uh you didn't
have any time to yield back but uh
again i think
i would like to re-establish the rules
that we both worked out on both sides
um i think the questions you asked were
great questions i think the answers were
great answers but if we're going to keep
control of this process here because i
know our guys are just itching to get
even and i'm encouraging them not to do
that and we're asking everybody to use a
little common sense tighten up the
answers and if we can
we'll keep this under control i'd just
like to announce that dr harry
salem uh has joined the panel uh he's
the chief of the life sciences
department research and technology uh
directorate at the u.s army edgewood
research development and engineering
center for the department of defense
thank you for being here we apologize
for the mix-up i guess you're going to
be here tomorrow as well and uh so uh
uh welcome
mr chairman if you would stand and raise
your right hand
do you solemnly swear testimony you're
about to give these oversight
subcommittees is the truth the whole
truth is nothing but the truth yes sir
thank you
please be seated mr chairman i'd like to
make a correction my title is i'm the
chief scientist for life sciences at the
u.s army chemical biological defense
commands i apologize
we had incorrect information here and
thank you for pointing that out
the chair now yields to the chairman of
the full committee mr klinger thank you
mr chairman and i in turn would like to
yield my time to the gentleman from
indiana mr sauder
thank you mr chairman um
mr jamar
and did you know where the children were
in the compound as you were inserting
the gas
we were
our estimate was they were on the second
floor
the
area that once it started that
that mr potts alluded to
you know where were they during the fire
fight
um one of the reasons that once uh
the
very very near when the gunfire stopped
one of the reasons that the hrt members
rushed to the bus
with the hope that the children were in
that bus that was a safe place when they
like mr
rogers can describe that more but they
weren't exact but they weren't in fact
where you thought they were no sir um
did and also i think it's really
important that we don't just kind of i
mean politicians kind of slide and spin
but we can't have that out of the panel
you didn't say that you thought there
was a good likelihood like mr potts you
said 99
certain that they were going to fire on
the tank my personal opinion
the um
you know i'm trying to give you the best
answers i can give you here
my thought was that
but that's why we but i thought their
motivation was they feared entry so we
changed the plan we've broadened it out
where
we would take one tank up and firing on
that one tank
would be
just the one tank we could try to
convince them not to fire i was trying
to say
logic and you were hoping that they
wouldn't yes and you use reasonable
restraint starting i'm not questioning
that but you assumed you'd go to the
next level well no i i feared we would i
didn't say 90 is pretty certain well i'm
telling you it was it was
at this well one thing let me get back
to why i was saying that is because what
i didn't want was all the stuff to go up
at once
i mean
excuse me i'm not saying this very well
forgive me for taking your time what i
didn't want was incremental where we
come up with the bradleys over and over
where they face automatic fire over and
over again that's the context of that
right so then when you move to the next
step and you i understand that you had
planned if you saw a blockade or didn't
see anybody coming out to knock down the
walls would you have considered
to make escape routes in other words i'm
not suggesting maliciousness in locking
down the walls but would that not have
been considered an entry and did they
not consider that an entry which is why
they lighted the fire at that point
uh no i think they didn't light the fire
until noon
but wasn't that when the walls started
to come down they said no no no that
thing was before that but i think
remember we're telling them all the time
we're not coming in come out
please come out don't sit in there don't
don't settle it this way remember this
is six hours you discussed the
possibility with the attorney general
that it might be perceived that if
you're knocking down the compound walls
as they see the end that they might
light the fire at that point was that
discussed
i don't think we
specifically fire the the idea was that
when we
if they weren't coming out that we had
to make holes to provide escape
okay if that's why we did it if they had
been coming out we wouldn't have made
the holes in the place that people had
been coming out so i presume they
couldn't get a malicious attempt to do
that what i'm wondering is because as i
read the transcripts with mr sage he was
trying to warn them saying come out
we're not trying to harm you and saying
that as he's doing it and then you can
hear him say spread the fuel well he
couldn't hear that then we didn't know
that was happening if we'd heard spread
the fuel we just stopped right then we
didn't hear that we didn't know that
until those tapes were enhanced we
weren't hearing that did you do well i
wanted to ask mr potts one other
question
did the attorney general know that just
seven months earlier during the standoff
with randy weaver the white separatist
in idaho that the fbi was apparently
warned against using the gas at that
point in the u.s marshals log obtained
states that the deployment of gas in the
residence represents a high degree of
risk to small children there may be a
one-year-old baby inside was she
informed that there already was a
warning inside the government that that
log is not correct
there was um
that that's an absolute incorrect
statement by the u.s marshals service
log
uh that the facts of that
are that
in idaho there were discussions about
what happens as as we do with any crisis
situation when you arrive there you
start trying to set up negotiations but
you also have to start planning for what
happens if we if
in on an emergency basis we have to
resolve this thing tactically
as a part of those discussions there was
discussions about whether or not
cs gas or some other kind of gas can be
used there
that
that never got any further than that
the discussions
when they first started we asked the
questions what would the impact be on
the children
while there was some investigation that
started into that some research and some
references
is part of the reason it didn't go
further because they decided not to do
it
yeah we decided not to do it and one of
the uh that's right we just we decided
not to use it but it had nothing to do
with information that had been gathered
that it would be have any kind of
negative effect on the children
thank you
[Applause]
mr white
thank you mr chairman um given all the
testimony we've had about uh
sinister devices and things i was
reluctant to sit down here because
this instrument was on my desk
but now i see that
the name larry mcintosh is written on it
so
if larry mcintosh is missing
some sinister device i want to make sure
it gets returned to him
and i'm happy to see that it didn't
explode when i
when i contacted it
is somebody named larry mcintosh looking
for some
some device that looks like this
the mind control machine oh
maybe so let me put it back there
mr chairman i just have two questions um
uh one is a completely worthless
question but uh
that's probably
not unlike many of the questions that
have been asked throughout the course of
this hearing
one i think
may serve some
useful purpose
in the context of this hearing
and the future conduct of events
but i would submit to the panel that
both questions i think
in my mind are
essentially the same question and so i
want to ask this this ques these two
questions to you and ask you each to
respond
and i won't wait until the end of my
five minutes uh to do that we appreciate
that
uh
the first question which the one which i
think is a worthless question
uh
is if you had this to do over
again knowing what you know now
what would you do
differently
the second question that i
have to ask which i don't think is a
worthless question but may may be
exactly the same
consequence
is informed by the experiences you had
at waco
and what resulted following the
decisions and actions
you took at waco
what would you do differently
in a future situation
similar to the situation
at waco
and if i can get each of you gentlemen
in whatever capacity
you
made decisions or took actions at waco
to answer those questions
if you perceive them to be the same
question fine i do
uh
but um i'd like to get each of your
response maybe i'll start at
this and
well actually you were probably more
directly involved so let me start with
you
in case the chairman once wants uh to
abbreviate we'll have the most directly
involved people
uh having gone first mr potts
there's a pretty broad questions i'll
try not to do like i did last time and
give quite as long an answer but i
it's
knowing what we know now
knowing that they were going to light a
fire
uh what would we do differently
[Applause]
if we knew that they were going to light
a fire
one of the problems of trying to figure
out how we would have done this
differently is that we we had this
emergency plan that if they were going
to commit suicide
the plan was to
put gas in there to try to get them out
and prevent the suicide and to knock
holes in the walls so that they could
come out those who did not want to
participate
clearly
we would do anything we could to have
prevented this mass suicide from
occurring
i think that the negotiations as as
byron sage said earlier
one of the frustrations about this case
is not knowing
not being able to tell everyone who
comes behind us
i would love to have left a note on my
desk when i left as assistant director
of cid that says if you ever have
another waco
here's how you resolve it i
we did everything we could from a
negotiation standpoint
and then when it finally got to a
certain point
where we believe based on all of the
information that's coming in from all of
the experts you ask why why didn't we
wait longer
one of one of the one of the reasons is
because of all the psychological and
behavioral science information we had
that indicates that what koresh really
wants at the end of all of this at the
end of the day whether it's a time that
you pick by doing something or whether
it's a time that he chooses because he
decides now is my time to do it is that
he wants a fight with the authorities
he wants to to end this thing that he
said in 1985 i started planning for a
battle with the authorities and he wants
to end it that way
when you're confronted with those kinds
of
of situations i think we'd have to go
into each one of these different and
deal with them and try to negotiate them
out and find out what the key is going
to be
we never we never were able to find that
key because i think the key to quresh
was
his ultimate goal was to have this type
of apocalyptic end
um are there little things we would have
done differently there there clearly are
i mean i
we probably wouldn't play the music
uh
there's all kinds of little things like
that that we've changed we've changed a
lot of policy issues in the fbi to make
things better in response to a crisis
we've put the negotiators and the
hostage rescue team together
under one command
we've done
much more advanced training not only of
field commanders but of fbi headquarters
executives on how do you respond to
these kind of crises we had hrt team and
the negotiators that trained all the
time and are the best in the world but
we had not given adequate training
to the commanders do i think that made
any difference in the way this came out
i absolutely do not i don't think you
could have had a better on-site
commander than jeff jamar
so there are changes that we've made but
in the situation itself
i don't think there's any easy answer
i think one way to answer your question
is let's say that we heard on one of our
overhears
that corey said if they come in if they
approach us in any way i'm going to set
the compound on fire
let's say we knew that
is it
we
our method would have been to work on
the people inside and find a way of
communicating with them which we tried
over the loud speakers that's where we
put the loudspeakers in
i think that the the the lesser items
that that
to that that mr potts just described i
agree with there's other changes we
would have made
but
if we had to know that that's the part
that that
when we know he's going to do that
that's of course that's what we sent the
microphones in
with the hope of learning what was in
his mind
uh
the the sad part is though
that in these circumstances
is when they hold
all the cards when when all
events are in his absolute control each
one has to stand on its own
i don't think you can presume anything
about anyone in these circumstances what
you have to do is learn from experience
i think uh
the fbi and all of law enforcement has
learned from what happened to us there
i think the whole country's learned i
think that's why i think these hearings
are so worthwhile
that we should be held responsible for
what we did and we should answer for
what we did
but the
i think that the changes
beyond
what we could do to him to change his
mind or change those people's mind
people in there's mind
limits us that way
i all you can do is take these and do
the best you can with them in each one
and
and keep your mind open and keep and
keep reaching out for all the all you
can all the information you can
and i can tell you that
everyone there put body and soul in just
to save those people inside there and
they'll be the same attitude wherever we
go we didn't we didn't run out of time
we didn't run out of money
we will continue to work on as hard as
we can on each one of these
congressman i think it's real clear
at least it is to us that had we had our
crystal ball been working that day
there would not have been an insertion
of tear gas into that compound knowing
that a fire was going to ensue
that's the answer to your first question
we would not have done it
the answer to the second question is a
little bit tougher what would we do in
the future
i assume if we had the same set of
circumstances
you know the problem in law enforcement
is that every decision has consequences
every decision this committee will make
concerning law enforcement will have
consequences if we decided for example
that we're not going to allow cs tear
gas to be used anymore into a compound
the consequences are going to be for law
enforcement that you've just taken away
a non-lethal tool that they've used in
order to resolve
hundreds if not thousands of barricaded
situations
so i just offer that as an example of
the consequences for every decision we
make
i don't have an answer
for really for the second part of the
question about what we do in the future
but we clearly will uh take all of the
lessons learned here and many of the
things that mr jamar and mr possibly
alluded to changes have already been
made and we're trying to make it better
congressman watt uh from a negotiation
standpoint
um
this is not and it's been said before
it's not an exact science uh no one has
all the answers there's no guarantees
but you enter into it it's very
challenging
course to attempt to
to pursue as a negotiator this was by
far the most challenging
situation i'd ever been faced with in my
25 years in law enforcement
i'm extremely proud of the makeup of the
team of the efforts that went into it by
every single negotiator and those that
supported the negotiation team from a
uh
clerical standpoint all the way up to uh
to the coordinators
um
i'm also devastated by the loss of life
i think everybody that that participated
in this thing and
put such a one-on-one effort into
contacting those people over 68 people
contacted
some
extensively
will forever have an effect on all of us
but
we employed some of the most innovative
techniques i've ever seen brought to
bear against the situation
i almost said a situation like this
there's never been a situation like this
and god forbid there ever will be again
but by experience the second
question that you have i would say
a lot of steps have been made
by the bureau internally
to address that very issue we need to
learn from each and every situation we
have we've had critiques
we've explored every possible
everything that worked as well as
everything that didn't work sometimes
you don't get as much emphasis on those
things that did work
we saved the lives of 35 people during
the course of this thing nine additional
people that came out on the on the last
day and then the two individuals that
came in and out that's a total of 46
people that's lost
on
the public sometimes i'm proud of that
from a negotiation standpoint
most significant thing i think in
hindsight is probably the coordination
between all elements
there's an aggressive effort undertaken
now under the critical incident response
group headed up at quantico to ensure
that that's done at the very highest
level of exchange and professionalism
and that will help
but all of these things hopefully will
make us a little more prepared for the
next one because
unfortunately there may very well be a
next one
congressman in my role seeking expert
advice on cs i would still go to
edgewood maryland and ask for the best
person available in that
it is the center for that the only
difference would be is that i would
probably ask for dr harry salem now
which i could not do then because i was
not familiar with him based on my
experience now of his dedication to
research and finding facts based on hard
scientific data
congressman watt i was asked to advise
on the safety and toxicology of cs
the advice i gave was that if chemical
had to be used the riot control agency s
would be the agent of choice it is
considered
the safest and most potent
riot control agent that we are aware of
based on the scientific literature
as a practicing toxicologist i spent the
last 40 years
working to save lives and to improve the
quality of life for the human race
personally i was deeply moved and
devastated by the tragedy that occurred
at waco
and for the regrettable loss of life
that occurred there
my meeting with the leaders
of the team who was involved with this
and the decision makers
i was convinced that their they were
motivated by the same motivation that i
had was to save lives
and if i had to make the decision again
based on the scientific literature
the safest and most potent riot control
agent that we know of is cs
thank you mr chairman
i uh
i would again like to just remind
members uh the last two members took 35
minutes and there's no discussion or
criticism of the content of the
questions there are good questions and
certainly good answers
i just want to try to appeal to
everybody's common sense here we do have
a five-minute rule
and before our side gets carried away
we're trying to get even on this thing
and we lose control of this i just like
to keep and ask for everybody's
cooperation
thank you very much
you're doing an excellent job
thank you mr conyers i appreciate that
mr barr
thank you mr chairman um mr potts uh not
to get us off on a tangent but your your
answer to uh congressman sauder's uh
question intrigued me uh with regard to
the uh
i think you said the uh the ruby ridge
crisis analog was inaccurate when it
states
quote the deployment of gas into the
residence presents a high degree of risk
to small children
uh close quote
but what i'm saying is i think there's
more to that sentence which says
the reason that it wasn't done
that there was a decision not to use cs
gas at ruby ridge was because of the
high risk that it poses to young
children i quoted you the whole sentence
okay and and that's
they're
we never reached that conclusion because
we never got to a final decision as to
whether to use it or not
we asked the question
during the course of it what kind of
effect will this have on the children
and that was being researched but we
never got to the point of where all of
that information came in we certainly
never got enough information in from my
standpoint or pro probably from anyone
else's associated with that standoff to
use the gas at that time okay so you're
not you're not you're not stating that
that this sentence
uh is uh somebody inserted it in there
and properly or made it up
i'm just simply saying that it's not it
doesn't accurately reflect the
information that we had and the
information upon which we based the
decision not to use you're not saying
that that the deployment of gas into a
residence doesn't present a high degree
of risk to small children
what i'm say
what i i would defer to our expert on
that we we did not believe even in waco
that it that it was a high risk to
children
well okay
just you haven't clarified it
sorry i tried pardon
i'm sorry i was trying to clarify it i
apparently wasn't you you may you may
have been but but uh but you didn't okay
um uh mr potts uh you also said i i
believe that
uh the mr jamar submitted the gas plan
to you around the 22nd of march is that
correct no sir 27 20 that's why i said
the 22nd okay 2-2
okay
27th
27th okay
okay
and then there was discussion of the
plan
for the next couple of weeks yes sir
okay
and then on the
eighth and ninth
uh
you and mr clark went to waco
and discussed it further in waco among
other things that you did there actually
we we went to seventh and eighth
but there was there was a tremendous
amount of discussion just at waco and at
headquarters about the plan itself
when i first heard about the plan i was
very much opposed to it
mr jamar and i had several conversations
on the phone
i believe that
after one particular conference call
that we had where we discussed whether
we were at the point where where we
should move to this next step or not
um both of us were a little frustrated
that
the information that we had may not
may not be meshing right
and so when i got home that night around
11 mr jamar called me at home and we had
another lengthy discussion about whether
or not this was the right thing to do at
this time or not
when
when he did that he suggested he said i
think what really needs to occur here
for you to have the full impact of
what's going on in waco is that you and
floyd clark or someone needs to come
down and okay
i'm not really and that's what i don't
know why in the 70s i didn't ask you
about why you went there i just said
then you did go there right and you
discussed the cs plan further that's
right uh was the first briefing of the
attorney general on the ninth
no sir it wasn't on the ninth we
we briefed uh the director director
sessions at that time and doug gao on
the ninth
and then the director sessions after
considering it and asking questions and
being briefed himself
then set up an appointment with the
attorney general from monday the 12th
okay there was no briefing of the
attorney general about it on the on the
ninth not by the fbi no sir
by somebody else i i don't know i
believe that there were people in in
waco on the seventh and eighth from the
department i'm just reading from mayhap
from this report is this one inaccurate
no i don't believe it is i believe that
it says that on the ninth
that probably mark richard informed
people at the department of justice that
there was discussions within the fbi
about a gas insertion plan
and then director sessions having been
briefed on the ninth
called the attorney general and asked
for a briefing time on the 12th and
that's when that occurred
okay so at the uh
when it states in here that uh quote on
april 9 richard and reynolds briefed the
attorney general on the results of their
trip to waco that didn't concern the cs
gas
it didn't necessarily concern that the
cs gas they may have mentioned to her i
don't know that
gentlemen this uh this follows
a footnote
i quoted you from page 259
and this follows
after a footnote on page 258
quote pods pointed out that the plan was
really
just an extension of the emergency
assault plan which had been in effect
since the beginning of the standoff
was that the context in which initially
the cs plan was presented to the
attorney general
no sir not at all what i was talking
about is the specifics of the plan
itself
uh was certainly an extension of our
original emergency response plan
gentleman's time has expired mrs lofgren
thank you
thank you mr chairman uh dr salem if you
could answer very promptly because of
the time constraints yesterday i asked
really what some of my constituents have
asked is whether there is a gas
available that is
safe but would render people unconscious
rather than a reaction and if not
is there work underway to develop such a
substance and if it's not classified
information can you answer
whether that's being pursued or whether
there's anything available
the only type of things that are
available
to do that would be the anesthetic gases
and the anesthetic gases are used in
hospital situations so
cardiovascular effects it can be treated
uh so it couldn't be used unless you had
that kind of equipment no certain
concentration has a tighter control
thank you very much i have um
a letter it's in the packet that all the
members have
dated march 28th from kerry jewell's
father and i i wonder if mr potts mr
jamar or mr rogers could answer some
questions about it it's to the president
of the united states and i'll read just
a few phrases not the whole letter
because it's so long he says one year to
the day before the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms attempted to serve
wards i won custody of my daughter
carrie from her mother sherry jewell who
was then a member of the cult and is now
among those within the compound
females including children as young as
12 were known to be taken by howell
koreshes as wives he would impregnate
them as soon as possible with his holy
seed girls as young as 13 having given
birth to his children my own daughter
told the authorities in waco on february
22nd of this year of how he had sexually
assaulted her when she was ten kerry's
mother participated in the assault by
delivering carrie to him in a hotel room
having full knowledge of his intent
kerry recently described me how she was
taught by koresh and other followers to
commit suicide when i asked her why this
was taught she said that quresh preached
that they had to be martyred to gain
salvation the plan was to instigate an
assault by the authorities in which they
would be killed but if the feds could
not be baited correctionist followers
would commit suicide mr president i feel
that
koresh has placed you and the agents
under your command in what amounts to a
no-win situation he has planned this for
years and he knows full well that
politically there is no right move for
authorities to make against him if they
attack people of both sides will die and
the authorities will be blamed if
authorities continue to stand back and
wait the public will grow weary and come
to think of the federal forces as
ineffectual stand back too long and the
davidians will simply resort to plan b
suicide and then the authorities will be
blamed for not stepping in kerry and i
have had several long talks about how
this crisis affects her and we've
discussed her concerns for her mother
she understands that it is likely that
another assault would result in the
deaths of many of her friends in the
compound her response daddy it's better
that some of them die than all of them
correctionist followers are using
america's values to hold us all hostage
those who are inside of there by choice
america did not create this situation it
was designed by a pedophile with a bible
in the in one hand and a gun in the
other please mr president end it now
my question i am sure the president
didn't get this i mean he gets millions
of letters a year but my question to the
three of you is whether you had received
this letter been booted down to you in
any way
whether this information if you had it
made a difference in your thinking
whether it matched your own
uh
whether you saw the cs gas attack as
sort of an in-between spot of where
carrie jewell's dad was and since we're
looking for improvements for the future
whether information such as this as this
from a former cult member or someone who
was in communication with people in the
complex would have been helpful
is there something we need to do to
establish a different information flow
in the future thank you
i don't remember seeing that letter
but i can i can tell you that i think
that it was a fairly accurate assessment
of where we felt we we were
in terms of it being an
exceptionally difficult situation to
resolve
that he was
not going to come out voluntarily we
were told by
park dietz psychiatrist on march 5th
that this standoff
quresh has everything he needs
inside that compound all his basic goals
and needs are being met inside the
compound
there was always a concern that he would
do something to lure us inside so that's
the kind of that that information if you
could just answer whether it would make
a difference and i don't want to abuse
my time so mr jamar we did do that we
went out and contacted everyone who'd
been inside that cult that we could to
try to locate them and see what their
perception was going to be of what would
occur inside so that information is
certainly valuable and we tried to
collect it
let me just answer this you got you got
one and uh by agreement with with the
minority mr schumer and i uh are going
to limit this little game i don't mean
to call it a game but two people
in other words pick any two and you get
a response once the red light hits and
we both agree that that's a fair process
to go move it along
okay so you pick one more person for
another response mr truman's agent
we did a
very in-depth research on the
possibilities of suicide
i don't know when that letter was
received at the white house but if it
was received in time we would have
received it i'd be surprised if we did
not i don't remember it specifically but
i'd be very surprised if we did not was
not promptly sent to us
uh
all that was part of the process as mr
potts said i think his his uh
perceptions were
very very very very accurate but
he would have been interviewed probably
or his daughter might have been
interviewed as part of that suicide
review
so we would have that information and uh
we were in a position to review
all the letters we got some crazy
letters and we got some some well
intended uh thoughtful letters too and
they were all reviewed from all sorts of
sources we had people
uh looking at it as best we could um and
that that's
about to answer to that i think thank
you
thank you thank you very thank you very
much uh mr early
thank you mr chairman it's
i'm going to yield mr barb before i do i
want to
yet again revisit my sense of
frustration with respect to the
political environment surrounding these
surrounding these hearings and
this is really a good panel to do it
with because i want to congratulate the
panel and i just want you all to know mr
jamar particularly your comments
what you all have told us so far today
really goes to the bottom line of the
hearings we want to know what y'all
think went wrong
new policies new procedures
that you have instituted to correct
uh what went wrong at waco
and i for one and i think everyone i
speak for everyone both sides they all
appreciate that that's the purpose of
these hearings
because the political environment is
such that
the other day we had a member on the
other side of the aisle
characterize a republican
depiction of mr karash
as a child molester and i kept list here
child molester pedophile pervert evil
con artist liar snake arms trafficker
and real bad guy
as an attempt at rehabilitation
and
i opened the paper today and i see a
writer from the post
has now labeled
the same depiction of mr karesh
as a republican attempt
at a posthumous or a posthumous attempt
to act as mr crush's protector
that's a frustration that we all feel
with respect to the political
environment surrounding these hearings i
know you all appreciate that
most of us here want to get to the
bottom line with respect to the real
issues surrounding waco and with that
comment i'll yield to mr barr
thank you i have a question for mr sage
but while i'm doing that mr potts if if
you would please take a look at page 101
of the
report of the deputy attorney general
and that indicates uh
even clearer than the previous citation
that i made to you that there were
discussions with the attorney general
on on april 9th
concerning specifically the cs plan
mr sage am i
i just and again i just want to
clarify something
uh the
page that we that we have here
concerning
the
uh loud the language that was given over
the loudspeaker during the course of the
time when the cs was being inserted yes
sir it says among other things this is
not an assault
and i believe that that was being
spoken over a loud speaker so it could
be heard
inside
was that occurring simultaneously with
the armored vehicle going up to the
building
the
the initial
the initial broadcast was as the armored
vehicle was the cev was just turning
onto the driveway as i understand it was
far from the building the building but
am i i was i think that they stated that
this was broadcast over and over again
that is correct that's why i said the
initial broadcast was well before the
vehicle i'm not i'm not asking about the
initial broadcast and i was wondering if
this language including the words this
is not an assault was being broadcast
over the loudspeaker during the course
of the time when the vehicle was going
up to the building
this is being inserted this is not an
assault we are not entering your
building and it was repeated several
times okay while the vehicle was
going up to the building
yes sir and throughout the morning for
six hours okay uh
mr jamar
did you i think there was some
discussion earlier
about
what the electronic surveillance could
pick up
during until
the capability went when playing
uh
terminal 19 on the 19th on the 19th
um
i say i recall that that mr ray yan who
was the the lead prosecutor for the
department of justice in this case
told the committee that he could hear
the language we talked about earlier
about the fires or and the fuel and so
forth uh the first time he heard it
without any sort of enhancement
the first time you heard the tape yes
i think the
the explanation that i received was that
the when we were listening there's a
difference between listening to a tape
and listening to a live
broadcast
okay the tape may pick up something that
the ear cannot it can record it
i think that was the problem we were
losing was
from
it was being transmitted by radio
to a point on telephone lines back to
the monitors for safety reasons the
monitors were not forward
am i am i clear on that the
radio
i don't understand how the transmission
itself works well i don't understand
because i've listened myself right to a
number of undercover operations and
while i certainly understand that there
may be a lot going around uh
outside the person who's listening
uh certainly sitting in a command post
listening uh in my experience you're
generally able to pick up pretty much as
much as you can off of the unenhanced
team i can tell you the monitors didn't
hear it the people monitoring did not
hear it i'm trying to find a plausible
explanation i've been searching this
forever i would love to have known that
that was going on and the only thing i
can they've been told i'm not a
technician by any stretch of imagination
is that that could have been the problem
i'm not saying it was but the monitors
did not hear that and we didn't know
that until we heard the tapes and some
of which had been enhanced
okay so that that may be one problem
area that
certainly no problem area
could i just clarify
i'm sorry could i just clarify that
comment on one on page 101 mr barr
mr barr i
what what that is is information that
was coming from waco this would have
been
taken from logs and information that
that at the at the site
and what the site is saying is that they
were contacting us
discussions began at fbi headquarters
and with the attorney general to
determine if the plan would be approved
i believe from the fbi standpoint the
only contact that we had with the
attorney general on the ninth would have
been director sessions phone call to her
to say that we we want to brief you on
the 12th regarding the plan
i think that's consistent
okay thank you yes sir minority
you want to move chairman mrs slaughter
from new york thank you mr chairman uh
dr salem i don't know if you're the
correct person to ask about this but i
don't know that we're going to have the
correct person either we heard last
night from a psychologist on cs gas and
some chemists
but my understanding dr salem is that
autopsy showed that every child that
died
died of asphyxiation from the fire is
that your understanding i have not seen
the autopsy reports
are you aware of any person have you
ever seen or heard of any person who has
died from cs gas exposure no ma'am
most of the all the published literature
that i have seen they all say that there
are no
authenticated cases where anyone has
died following cs exposure i know there
have been a lot of allegations
and a lot of
conjecture on that point but the
literature there
does not reveal any authenticated cases
i i'm hoping that the persons who call
witnesses here and i don't have any idea
who they're going to be
uh we'll bring in someone who can tell
us about the autopsies on
sage do you have any information on that
yes ma'am uh after the 19th of april i'm
being the supervisor in charge of the
austin nueco offices i also assisted in
the coordination of the fbi resources
crime scene and part of that was the
accumulation of information to be
reported to headquarters from the
medical examiner's office in
tarrant county dr parwani
i don't have a definitive bottom line i
wish i did as far as
exact
numbers of identified
victims and and so forth but we did have
uh reports as i understand it from some
things i've read you've had you've
identified almost every victim yes ma'am
right yes ma'am but there's
we still the numbers are still
approximate
we're trying to give this panel and the
american public absolutes and we just
don't have a bottom line yet from the
medical examiner's office but
children perished from gunshot wounds at
least four of them
one from a stab wound and two from blunt
trauma that may well have been part of
the
that
bunker-like building collapsing on them
but
none
according to the reports that we
received at the command post and
forwarded that information to
headquarters
and
died from any effect
of the cs gas i do not profess to be an
expert in the field but i'm
i'm telling you what the reports were
that came to me at the command post in
waco
it would seem those should be available
for us i certainly certainly would like
to see them
mr rogers uh i i wanted to give you an
opportunity to talk this morning too you
were on the scene
yes ma'am i was uh and as i
see from the brief notes that i have
here
it says that you went to an underground
tank i'm not exactly clear on what that
is is that what was that the buried bus
yes ma'am it's been referred to there
what did you find there
when we went into the buried bus what we
anticipated and hoped we'd find would be
the children where they had
placed them for safety
uh during this
uh
we went uh
i don't believe we have a photo up there
uh right now
but uh
i'd like to see one if we could if we
haven't have a
they had placed a school bus underground
and covered it with uh
with
dirt
and then the in that particular
photograph it's in would you point it
out
it's in the lower part of the photograph
as you look at it
they had a partial uh
building foundation being
constructed and there was a tunnel that
they also constructed from the partial
foundation that went into the front door
of the bus again all this is underground
and then the bus went right up to
a portion of it was actually underneath
the edge of the compound building
and they had built a trapdoor in the
floor in the hallway at the end of the
hallway that went down into the rear of
the bus
so it was a contiguous uh structure once
they had completed their construction
and as soon as
the fire department arrived
i directed them to start putting water
into the area where the bus was
in the hopes that we could cool it down
about 17 agents uh of the hostage rescue
team then entered
that uh about waist-deep water in that
foundation
this is water from the fire department
no ma'am this is water from from rain in
waco and and just uh settlement water
that accumulated there your time has
expired
could i have just a second more cause i
think we took time to put the photo up a
quick second thank you mr zoo
anyway ma'am they went in uh into
through that water uh filled with the
human uh excrement that they had dumped
in there there were actually bodies in
there that they had placed and there
were rats went through this tunnel
and then broke into the bus and uh found
that there were no children there was no
one in there but the air was cool it was
fresh there was no gas there was no
smoke from the fire
and uh but they had not chosen to place
their children in there
thank you mr rogers
okay thank you
okay
[Music]
mr potts
you were a uh
a key decision maker at ruby ridge as
well as at waco is that correct yes sir
and um
mr jamar would call you
for approvals
i mean we were you basically acting as
waco yes sir right
and uh
as
on the issue of uh
on the cs gas at ruby ridge
was that considered at one point there
and then abandoned and if so why
it was one of many options that were
being discussed should there have to be
some kind of a tactical resolution
it was it was never uh
it was never necessary to make a yes or
no decision
uh we we did not
necessarily decide against it but we we
did not decide to go forward with any
gas and and there would have had to have
been a lot more discussion and review
of facts before we would have made such
a decision when the reference on on this
uh marshall's log was indicated you
discredited that i i discredited as
being that that's not correct that we
made a decision not to use it
because of harm to children and i i'd
also like to point out that at ruby
ridge uh i have some information that
there was there were other types of
gases that were being discussed that the
marshals had and i
that was not cs gas because this may be
returning to that was raised about the
deployment of gas into the residence
because of the high degree of risk of
small children the possibility that
one-year-old baby was inside
but but you're saying that that's not
correct what i'm saying is that we never
made a decision
uh we did we discussed whether or not it
would be harmful or not to the children
and had started to research that there
was no conclusion and there was no final
decision about wouldn't that be just a i
mean wouldn't that be a
kind of a
it may not have been a red light but at
least a yellow light a major area of
concern if if something like that was
discussed openly
and even though may some may try to
discredit but
wouldn't that be a good reason to be
very cautious in the use of cs gas
at waco if from just from what you
learned that's why yes sir that's why we
looked we didn't learn anything from
ruby ridge in terms of gas
the effects of gas but just the
information that you had out there as
you were making decisions we didn't have
any information out there that indicated
that cs gas was harmful to children so
so how did they get this information i
don't know sir okay
uh did mr hubbell ever tell you that
either he or the president wanted to
approve any shift
away from the negotiation plan
not mr hubble no sir stewart gerson told
me
very early in the operation he actually
told the director director sessions who
who informed me and then i told jeff
jamar
that the president had had adopted that
that we were going forward the correct
way with negotiation and he wanted to be
advised if there was any change any
change and so he was in agreement with
the philosophy of negotiating if that
was the change he wanted to know and be
involved that's my understanding of what
mr gerson told the director sessions so
tell me about your relationship with mr
jamar
like how many
how much time every day would you be in
contact
we would talk several times a day
sometimes at length were you ever
involved in in in the information that
we received uh relative to the to the uh
to the coming out plan that the two
attorneys talked about the other day
there were discussions early in in april
i about
a coming out plan just like there were
in early march
that's separate from the discussions
about
preparing the manuscript on the seven
seals which started in on april 14th but
but the one on the 14th um
were the two attorneys that that
talked about that the other day and gave
his testimony mr jamar
indicated that he didn't think that they
were serious
they felt that it was very serious um
the next day i believe mr sage talked to
mr hubble for two hours
um
and and i think you indicated i'll let
you answer that directly that you did
not
did you talk to mr hubble about that
plan
yes sir i did you did so between you and
mr hubble mr potts all three of you
decided to move forward
in spite of that plan
i think it's an overstatement that i
decided to uh i wasn't in a position to
make any uh command decisions in this
and it was not brought into that
conversation for that purpose who made
that decision
sir all i know was i was asked to give a
candid straightforward assessment of
negotiations and that's what i did did
mr potts did you make that decision
certainly
the recommendation that we had from waco
when my discussions with jeff jamar
were that this is not
a serious effort on the part of crash
based on
contacts with judy snyder and steve
schneider who who verified that they
hadn't even received the first page
of any uh of the first seal to edit
so all of that was was certainly
considered one thing we did say mr
chairman
jeff jamar said it i said it the
attorney general said it floyd clark
everyone else
if there's any
change in the hope that this thing can
be resolved differently up to the last
minute
than we need to know the question that
that i had in all due respect are you
the one that made that decision or did
you pass it under the attorney general
the president mr hubble or anybody else
or did you just decide no we're not
going to pass that on
did you make the decision mr mr jamar
made a decision on the scene i made a
decision based on his recommendation i
passed it along to my boss who passed it
along to director sessions who i assume
pass it on to the white house i i don't
i don't have any information that
director sessions had any contact with
the white house no sir
but you did pass it on the attorney
general though yes okay thank you very
much
i'm going to pass on on the left
to the right
mr coble from north carolina i thank the
gentleman the gentleman from maryland
earlier referred to this washington post
article implying that someone's
attempting to protect courage
folks i think that is unfortunate indeed
no one so far as i know on this panel at
any time is protecting or defending
david korish
i'm getting tired of having to repeat
that folks in my district who are
viewing these hearings don't read it
that way
people in america i don't think see
anything in this hearing
as coming down on the side of course so
let me set that aside for the moment let
me revisit last night just a minute mr
chairman because this is i have a quirk
with this sort of thing
uh this is my third hearing so it may
have been mentioned earlier but we had
two witnesses from great britain last
night
and the implication was that the justice
department got them here and paid their
way well folks the justice department
didn't pay the way the taxpayers paid
their way in this town the implication
is always oh this is congressional money
or this is fbi money well this is
justice but it's taxpayers money just a
little quirk that i wanted to
make clear for the record
the other day when mr zimmerman told us
about the plan of surrender now folks
i'll admit this is subject to
interpretation
mr zimmerman thought that plan of
surrender was about to come to fruition
others i'm sure think that it was
nowhere near fruition but when he told
that story gentlemen
i had had a pain in my stomach
now i'm not a delicate fragile sort
i'm not implying that i'm mr macho but
my point is i'm not overly emotional and
over overly sensitive i don't normally
feel pain when i hear a story
but when i heard that story
i could visualize all the death the
death being
avoided all the suffering being avoided
come out surrendering let's get on with
it now having said all that
mr sage i want us to revisit the april
15th telephone conversation you had with
mr hubble i think this is a crucial time
and i think that conversation
elapsed into about two hours if if i'm
not mistaken
during that time
mr sage
do you remember whether or not you ever
used the word surrender
or i'm paraphrasing now but mr hubbell
there's a plan in in motion out here
uh mr zimmerman was talking about even
the texas rangers the other day
were familiar with the plan so obviously
folks knew about the plan
was that ever communicating mr sage to
mr hubble absolutely
the answer is absolutely we we discussed
uh
the
concept of surrender in in finite detail
including the same feelings that you've
expressed here were felt by me but felt
by all of us
when the promises to come out on the 2nd
of march
did not come to pass that same type of
of intent desire
commitment
and prayer is i'm sure what the defense
counsel was feeling and has expressed to
this council in good faith
uh we did express that we expressed also
the
consistency of the pattern of broken
promises no one
was attempting to
uh paint this in a particular fashion to
facilitate a certain end such as a
tactical resolution uh
what i portrayed to him was a uh during
the course of that conversation to into
the other parties uh
that participated on on the washington
dc end
of the conversation
uh was that it was a consensus and i
need to stress this of the negotiation
team this was not the the
singular my singular idea which was in
contrast to the rest of the negotiators
that had been there off and on the
entire uh period of time which at that
time was in the
uh i think close to 40 some odd days
the
what i expressed to him was was a
factual
chronology of exactly what efforts had
gone forward what successes we had
received including
at that time 35 people that had come out
but i also had to stress and all
fairness to him and to you and to the
american public
that at the time of that conversation it
had been 27 days since we'd received
anyone out
uh
and
maybe even more importantly it had been
41 days since we'd received any children
that's as of the 15th of april but yes
sir the surrender plan
was uh
it was discussed in detail because it
had not changed and that's a very
important part it had not changed
substantially
since the understanding that we had with
mr quresh allegedly on the 2nd of march
the only
change that had
been inserted was to facilitate
the ability to use defense counsel mr
say the chairman is going to come after
you and me both if we don't terminate
because the red light illuminates thank
you mr sage thank you mr chairman sir
thank you mr cobo mr brewster
thank you
i guess mr potts were you the one that
divides the plan on the intermittent use
of gas
and execution
no sir i certainly i certainly
participated in those discussions it was
actually
a team of people who devised that all of
the sacs
dick rogers floyd clark
it was everyone sitting down trying to
figure out how we could do it
and cause the less
likely violent response from inside okay
did the same team then decide that if
the
the tanks received fire
that you would immediately put major
quantities of canister's gas in them
there was a recommendation that in in
lieu of of returning fire
that that
we would recommend that the plan
indicate that if we receive fire that we
should put gas throughout the compound
in order to suppress the fire we were
receiving and he obviously had to expect
fire because the people had showed the
propensity to do that in the initial
rate so
actually we
we thought that it was a possibility but
we believe by the incremental
aspect of putting the gas into the
compound and also coupled with the fact
that we had made an announcement in
advance
that we may not in fact get fire okay
and uh the only one i saw in the bios
here that was present to talk with
attorney general was dr salem at the
time the cs gas was discussed were you
there or anybody else on the panel
involved in that
my understanding the attorney general
uh had great concern for the children as
far as using the cs gas was she made
aware
that if you receive fire in the
intermediate intermittent use of the gas
that you would
escalate it dramatically
was she aware of that when she approved
the deal
sir maybe i can answer that uh to my
knowledge we i briefed her on the entire
and full plan that we had at waco
did you specifically make her aware that
if you received fire
gunfire
that yes sir that was understood
that the answer is yes the answer is yes
that that if you received gunfire you
would escalate the use of the cs cash
okay and mr potts
uh
i've noticed you've been in several
positions
of authority there finally promoted to
his highest deputy director
and then recently removed from that
position what what has caused that
yes sir when i was appointed to the
acting position in
in january of this year
i think the director understood and i
understood that that it could be a
controversial situation because of waco
and ruby ridge
and i informed the director on that day
and i informed him every week thereafter
that if at any point this hurt the fbi
or hurt him
that i didn't want to be in such a
position i'm very proud of being a
special agent of the fbi and i'll serve
any position that uh that i'm asked to
serve
uh i think it came to that point where
is it not being helpful to the fbi for
me to be in that slot and the director
and i discussed that and
and uh
and that's what caused it
what is your position now i'm i'm
assigned to the quantico uh training
academy okay but you do feel you've been
fairly treated yes sir okay
can anyone tell me that what uh changes
have been made in fbi procedure or
whatever that might prevent uh
the culmination of an operation like uh
like waco in the future
has there been any changes
you want to do
we've made a lot of changes sir in terms
of policy and how we handle these things
so we the first thing we did was we
combined the rescued hostage rescue team
and and the negotiating element under
one command and they train together and
we think that's going to have a
significant impact uh on these in terms
of their coordination and communication
the other thing we did is we selected
fbi hq executives and we selected field
executives and we have given them
extensive training on on hostage and
barricade situations if if we could get
something to us in writing those changes
i would appreciate one quick question
looking at it it's obvious to me that at
least for adults cs gas could not have
been a problem as far as getting out of
the building when the fire started in
your opinion
why did the davidians not come out
were there barricades across the doors
had walls falling in
what
i know a human
any of us can think about yeah we'll
stay in a building burn up i don't think
many people would do it and i don't
understand why they didn't come out i
think it's a combination i think some
were probably
convinced had they left that compound
that their salvation would
would be in
the balance they were convinced that's
why they were there that's why they
stayed the whole time with him that's
what didn't come out during the 51 day
siege
that they would believe that their
salvation rested with david korsh
i would i can't imagine human being not
fleeing gas or a fire
so it had salvation
okay
maybe shot to prevent it and prevent it
from leaving
the
uh combination of those those two i
think probably were 90 of them some
people got out
some people got out and didn't didn't
bring anybody else with them
which again tells me that
there was control on who could come out
and who couldn't
and that person was david coerce
to control and i i believe that
the highest percentage of those people
were they stayed in there because they
thought their eternal salvation
rested on that decision anyone else have
a different
idea thank you
thank you thank you
the chair now recognizes mr henry hyde
the chairman of the full committee on
judiciary
mr hyde thank you mr zelif um
i want to preface my remarks by
trying to
den
identify myself with mr ehrlich who has
talked about not taking sides we have
been portrayed as anti-law enforcement
and i just want to say i've spent my
legislative career supporting law
enforcement i think what you people had
to do
was
one of the most difficult assignments
imaginable
you're underpaid you're overworked and
51 days out in the plains of texas
confronting a situation requiring you to
be at the ready constantly
is a very debilitating
adventure and
i have nothing but the highest praise
for law enforcement generically
but that doesn't mean we can't learn
from mistakes
errors in judgment
absences of of prudent
utility and i think that's our duty
because frankly
i am
bewildered in the wake of jonestown
why more time wasn't spent and somebody
not out in the plains of waco but maybe
in a nice comfortable office in
washington didn't immerse themselves in
the religious
tenants of this branch davidian group
because i think
judgments were made that they were
hostages and i think that's wrong
judgments were made that they would
react to the gas and other things the
noise as normal people would and they
weren't normal people in the sense that
they had a belief system that was very
abnormal and very different but mrs
sparks tried to get through to somebody
she understood something about their
theology the two lawyers garen and
zimmerman understood something about the
theology and the negotiators for the fbi
could have i believe
and it's easy to say from hindsight
because you tried and you tried
but could have known that gas wouldn't
drive them out and it didn't the noise
wouldn't drive them out and it didn't
but they could have been
shall i say
it out through the bible or through some
other way but i don't think enough
attention was given to that
now i asked the question mr sage said if
i was in there i would be out in a new
york minute
was it reasonable to assume that these
parents who have devoted themselves to
this courage
evil person who were taught that the
outside world was babylon and that an
fbi attack was the beginning of the
apocalyptic end
would pick up their infants and run out
into the embrace of the babylonians
or is it more reasonable to assume they
would pick up their suffering children
put wet rags over their mouths and try
to find a remote corner
where they could pray
and wait
in other words the question isn't what
would you do or i do but if the gas were
coming in but what would a branch
davidian do and i don't think
much attention was given to that and
again i'm very surprised in the wake of
jonestown that somebody didn't
understand
you're dealing with bizarre
but fervent beliefs and the true
believer
can be approached not through
tape recordings of rabbits being slain
but
theological approaches and and i just
think
that was a major major flaw anybody wish
to comment yes sir
we did consider all of that we did
discuss religion we did consider the
branch davidians we also considered what
he would do in the long run and was
discussed earlier today i think to uh
um the the the loud noises were it was a
trivial thing i don't think had any
impact whatsoever it's going to start
until march 22nd that was all all the
the uh negotiation everything else we
had done
was at that point i don't think it
really made any difference but i think
for you to say that we did not consider
religion is not just not so mr chairman
and i i think that well you rejected it
obviously because because you thought
you could drive them out with tear gas i
didn't reject it sir we sent the uh the
tabor's tape in we sent phil arnold's
tape in for him to consider
we didn't reject everybody says we
rejected this this surrender plan we
didn't reject the plan sir we
we said we went in and let's look at are
they responding are the is korish doing
one thing he said he would do in writing
the manuscripts as the lawyers hoped he
would he didn't do that sir he
delay we got from them he's
steve steiner tells us he's responsible
for editing it we said we're going to
see something this is the 18th of april
here's four days that course could have
prepared a manuscript that the lawyers
hoped would be done in two or three days
four days later steve snyder tells us
i haven't seen the first page and you're
not going to get it until i edited it
so what does that tell me afterwards
he was working on it because they had
the they had the uh the disc
they had the disc why didn't they give
it to us
if they had that disc why didn't they
give it to us if if that was so
why didn't steve snyder tell us that
i can tell you why because his
instructions for 51 days was to stall us
give them the same oil run around every
day and he did that
nothing changed sir he
was their their attitude was the same
i'll tell you i was i wanted to to uh
to work i wanted that to work as much as
anybody else did but from off from the
discussion when our negotiators pressed
them where are you on the preparation of
them
of the
uh seven seal manuscripts if you review
those
transcripts of the of the negotiations
during those that period from 14th 15th
16th 17th you'll see how much the
negotiations negotiators pressed for
progress it was it was a constant
subject of discussion not one indication
that we could expect anything in the
near future which tells me sir that it
was just another
angle by chorus to stall and our great
fear was as long as he stalled and he
was waiting from his actions on the 19th
he was waiting for an opportunity to
fulfill his his
prophecy that he would do it on his time
and in his way and would be unsafe for
everyone well i regret my time is up
thank you thank you
we're in the
process of a vote committee stands
recess for 15 minutes
[Music]
you're watching the seventh of 10 days
of hearings on the incident in waco
texas in 1993. our coverage will
continue in about 10 minutes
first you'll hear from one of the
reporters who wrote on the waco hearings
glenn bunting of the los angeles times
we recently asked him about his 10 days
of coverage
glenn bunning of the los angeles times
as you look back on the the 10 days of
the waco hearings what's your assessment
of what you found out well
i think there are a lot of missed
opportunities we went into these
hearings a lot had been out had been
disclosed
in various reports that had come out by
both the justice department and the
treasury department
and this was an opportunity to come out
with a lot of new information and
answers to a lot of questions that
people had and for those that have
watched the hearings one of the things
that they probably saw right away is is
that the format and the nature of
congressional hearings did not lend
themselves to a lot of these questions
being answered so what we found was
a lot of politics at play i mean all you
had to do was tune into the beginning of
any session and you saw first thing in
the morning you know republicans uh
trying to make a big deal out of every
little thing and to
really bash the clinton administration
and various law enforcement agencies
that were involved here and the
democrats coming to the rescue you know
and saying nothing new nothing new
nothing new
and that just set the tone for the
hearings and you have 32 panel members
which is far too many to be asking
questions they each have five minutes
many of them give speeches uh bashing
the other side and then they get around
to the question
there were a few times that you had some
former prosecutors on the panel who
asked some good questions but when they
just started getting to the point where
you thought aha they're going to ask a
key question
they're going to get some answers bam
their time's up and then it goes to the
other side so there's no continuity
it's important to point out that
initially the panel had agreed both
sides
to doing it very differently and that
that each eye would select their their
own questioners and that not each of the
32 panel members would have to question
every witness and they would also have
more time to do so
but that broke down in partisan
wrangling the very first day and they
went to the the old system and it just
didn't work well in these hearings this
going head to head that you mentioned at
the beginning uh is that unusual for
this kind of hearing or was this
something unique that happened no that's
unfortunately it's not unusual at all i
think perhaps it was
done a bit more
because of the the sensitive nature of
the subject and particularly the
republicans attempts to somehow stick
this to president clinton
one thing that your viewers may not have
noticed in terms of nuance is that the
co-chairman representative bill zelle
from new hampshire
was constantly making the point that
president clinton was you know deeply
involved there was a washington times
story beforehand that said that you know
this might lead to impish impeachment
proceeding somehow without any real
specificity is what he was talking about
he was constantly critical of the
president he went on the national talk
shows on sunday i made a statement that
we're going to have you know the
equivalent of a smoking gun and we're
going to have new information about the
president's involvement
he also happens to be a bob dole
campaign official in new hampshire
so there is some
you know incentive for him to do that
and um
in the end there was no smoking gun
there was no new evidence and zelloff
continued to be critical and at one
point i asked in a press conference i
said well i'm confused are you saying
the president was too involved or not
involved enough
and he kind of was stunned by the
question and really didn't have an
answer for it so it's just a matter of
just throw it out there and criticize
without really having anything in
specific to go after
as far as your point is it's unusual
unusual unfortunately you know
congressional oversight hearings are
often billed as we're going to get to
the bottom of the facts we're going to
get the truth we're going to find out
all of
the information we're unable to find out
over the last two years but they often
boil down to just
a stone throwing match between both
sides
and
the difference is i think a lot of times
is you find that once that's kind of
done with and is accepted as part of the
process you get down the nitty-gritty of
asking the questions and getting some
answers we did get some answers but
the tone was such that i mean it began
every day during the break during the
questions and answers on both sides i
said a lot of questioners spent a lot of
time
responding to the other side and taking
their five minutes instead of asking
questions of witnesses i talked to a
number of witnesses afterwards it just
they came away shaking their heads
saying you know this is supposed to be a
fact-finding mission i mean you know
they just described it as a spectacle
and you can see people who come to
washington eager to tell their story
eager to get the facts out and they
witness this thing and then they just
walk away and find it mind-boggling in
talking of the witnesses was there any
particular witness that sticks out in
your mind as someone who was key to this
series of hearings
well i thought
there were a number of key witnesses
first day kerry jewell she was the 14
year old girl who told of being sexually
abused by koresh when she was 10 in a
hotel in a hotel room in texas she told
of beatings that took place and and
people being beaten by crash kids with
boat oars
she was
she really set the tone for the hearings
and you couldn't walk away without just
being really struck by this 14 year old
girl with her father there kind of
stroking her in the back and
and
supporting her and her doing what she
could to tell as best she could that
story
but again i mean
what we saw there was the democrats were
just um i mean they were giddy at her
testimony the idea that she had
basically made kresh out to be this
beast and they used her day in and day
out afterwards to say well you know
the attention is misplaced it shouldn't
be on law enforcement it should be on
david koresh and what a beast he is and
what a pervert and then the republicans
would continually come back and and say
that they were embarrassed that she had
to tell that testimony and she was
constantly the subject throughout of
this partisan wrangling but you walk
away with it it was really a brilliant
stroke on the democrats part to get her
on the first day and to tell that story
and all of a sudden kind of the mistakes
and the errors made by
law enforcement which there were a
number of them made here and serious
ones were kind of put in perspective
i think that hurt the republicans very
badly talk about her on the first day
last day was the attorney general what
came from that day
you know
not a lot new came from that day she had
been through this before
um and i think
perhaps more than any other witness the
format was very difficult because again
five minutes for somebody who uh is very
experienced at taking and fielding these
kinds of questions and she would have
very long drawn out answers a couple
times republicans in particular try and
interrupt her and stop her and say okay
but i want to ask this question and she
said wait a minute let me answer it my
way
and
i thought the format did not serve the
the the questioners in order to serve us
very well
it's interesting that she now says that
she had to do it all over again
she wouldn't have gone when she did um
she has kind of vaseline on that
throughout at times she's indicated that
she wouldn't and that you know
she had to do it over again she made the
same decision there a couple times she
came close to saying that that was the
first time she just uh you know
definitively made it clear that she had
do it over again she wouldn't have how
easy or difficult was this a story to
cover
it was a very difficult story to cover
because
there were two things at play here one
was just the long hours i mean you know
they would start
nine o'clock sometimes eight o'clock ten
o'clock in the morning and go through up
until midnight and we have deadlines to
meet here like everyone else and so it's
early evening deadlines and then there's
something you're wrestling with well do
you go on what's new and what's not new
because a lot of this stuff was not new
but it was buried in reports that our
readers certainly didn't get a chance to
read at least the vast majority of them
and a lot of people don't know what's
new and what's not new so it was always
a struggle of
this is good stuff it's strong stuff but
we've read it before or we've seen it
before so there was always that kind of
juggling act and and there were some
days where you just i mean there were
very few days we didn't have anything to
write about i mean we wrote every single
day i think out of the 11 days we were
on the front page of the la times eight
days so we gave it good treatment and
there was a little there was clearly a
lot more to write about as there is
often uh than we had space for um so it
was a challenge and it was just taxing
given the the grind of the you know 10
12 hours every day over a 11 day period
what was the feeling in the room the the
sense that you got that doesn't come
across on television
well
i think a couple of things one
there were times where
there were
two
sometimes even one democrat
and four or five republicans sometimes
down i think three or four republicans
sitting up
questioning witnesses
out of 32 panel members and i found it
interesting that if the camera had ever
been turned it had been kind of a wide
angle lens people would see that
while
early in the day you've got a full slate
up there and for janet reno everyone's
filling their seat for a lot of the
hours particularly as they stretched in
late at night in the less critical and
crucial witnesses
you found that a lot of not a lot of
members showed up and some of them
legitimately had other committee
business or other things but they didn't
have floor votes because they always
broke for a floor vote so that was not
there and so
i found it interesting that uh there
were a lot of times where you'd walk in
the sit in the room and i was there for
you know almost all the hearings that a
lot of members weren't there
um and that something just didn't kind
of come across
um also there was a
there was a lot of emotion in the room
at times i mean you had a time where you
had atf agents
sitting at a table and i thought it was
interesting that you had several of the
agents were involved in lawsuits they
were being sued they were suing others
they were suing one another i mean you
had a supervisor chuck serbian who
was the one who really um said let's go
ahead with the raid the initial rate
even though
they had been told by their undercover
officer inside that koresh knew about it
and um
it's a very emotional testimony and you
basically had both sides calling each
other liars and and i thought it was
interesting that and this happened
several times there was a pre-set
arrangement for seating
and people were supposed to be up and at
the last minute somebody would come and
take this name plate and put it at the
exact opposite end of the table because
there were people who just wouldn't
speak with one another and they wouldn't
be caught dead sitting next to one
another and so you saw that kind of
shuffling going on
before people sat down to testify there
was
a lot of emotion there were a lot of
times that
you know people came close to tears and
really had a hard time gut wretching
testimony
i thought that
some that came across i think at times
perhaps it didn't to viewers
but it certainly was not lost in the
room
in terms of who was who was doing there
and the fact that so many people i was
just struck by it was two years later
and you'd expect a number of people to
kind of recall it in a somewhat callous
fashion they've probably told the story
hundreds of times you know when they got
up there and with all the bright lights
and they're asked the questions i was
really emotional and trying for them and
i think people may have gained some new
respect for law enforcement and the kind
of role that they're forced to play and
the fact that
i mean there was description of of
people getting shot people witnessing
people getting shot the gunfire kind of
coming through
lots of death the carnage i mean that
was really brought to life uh by these
hearings i don't think people
i mean you know let's face it the whole
waco hearings were about what they're
about the government's mistakes the
screw-ups
really nailing the administration and
then how can we learn from these lessons
i think i think a lot of empathy and
support
that people have for law enforcement and
the reasons why i came out in this
hearing because you saw there are really
a lot of brave men and women that put up
a lot more than you and i put up with in
our jobs day in and day out and that
came through in the hearings
glenn bunning of the los angeles times
thanks very much sure
tomorrow we'll show the eighth day of
last month's house waco hearings we'll
hear more from fbi official larry potts
also testifying former fbi director
william sessions and former associate
attorney general webster hubble and
another panel of arson and fire experts
the ninth day of hearings airs thursday
with a panel of fbi special agents
and on friday we'll air the final day of
the house hearings with testimony from
attorney general janet reno
we now return to our coverage of the
seventh day of the waco hearings during
this final panel of the day we'll hear
from austin texas fbi official byron
sage harry salem of the u.s army
chemical and biological defense command
and san antonio fbi official jeffrey
jamar
let's go to michael you want to go to
michigan
the joint subcommittees on waco will now
come to order
chair yields to mr mica for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
dr salem
uh you were called by the minority and
you also briefed the attorney general on
cs gas
in fact you have been described by the
minority as the leading cs
gas expert among all the various
witnesses that we've heard
let me ask you three very important
questions
first as you sit here today
can you tell me if the cs gas at the
concentrations put into the compound
could not have killed the infants in the
compound
sir the concentrations that have been
calculated are well below uh the lethal
concentration for cs and as the
committee is aware
cs is really not a gas although it's
been referred to
you can you can tell me that the babies
and the infants listed on this autopsy
report
were not killed by css gas in the
concentrations in the compound in my
professional assessment
of the riot control agency s i have
reviewed the published
information and have evaluated
it and the concentrations required to
get an effective
riot control or to get the
involuntary flight response
is many thousands times
less than what is required to kill
secondly did you tell the attorney
general that infants would not die or be
harmed
i told her that there would be no
permanent harm
to children and this was based on what i
had reviewed
on the park in giamona paper and what
was reported by himsworth and concurred
by in
valentine's work
and also in the national research
council was which is a committee of the
national academy of sciences who've
reviewed the data and
in the best opinion of all of these
people
uh there is no increased sensitivity
to the effects of cs on infants young
adults and older people did those
studies specifically deal with young
infants
and children as in in this situation
the one case that has been referred to
where an infant had been exposed for up
to two to three hours
in a uh
what appears to be a very high
concentration
and was hospitalized with a chemical
pneumonia did recover was cured and only
after 28 days or after 28 days of
hospitalization it was released as cured
and this is have you well have you ever
written a an article or published
anything on cs gas and
particularly with children or infants no
i have not however
let me ask you if i may and i don't mean
to cut you off you said cs gas was best
for riot control that was your
opening statement if we put 24 children
and infants in this room and blast it in
periodically canisters of cs gas
and then even if we bash a hole in the
wall and for four hours what would be
the condition of those children after
four hours
well i think you'd have to make the
calculations of how much material is put
in the volume
you know several canisters if we tried
it in here
and then after 48 hours as as the plan
was to keep pumping this gas in there
wouldn't they have suffered or be
tormented
well i mean adults in military marines
suffer and are tormented just for just a
few minutes wouldn't they have been
tormented
and then
irregardless
uh of whether they died from the gas
they were suffocated by our actions uh
or or or
incinerated
well as i said i have not seen the
autopsy reports i don't know if they
were suffering well this is what what i
have to go on uh
i want to also now turn to mr potts i
chair the house civil service
subcommittee dealing with personnel
issues and
the conduct of federal employees
were you ever disciplined for your
actions or decisions relating to waco
ah no sir
were you ever disciplined
for your actions or decisions relating
to the incident of ruby ridge uh yes sir
i was
and after these actions were taken were
you elevated to another position and if
so what
well sir i was um so you were you were
disciplined
yes sir i represented then you were
elevated to wet position
i received a letter of censor uh based
on uh
ruby ridge and then and then what
position were you elevated to and then i
was elevated to a deputy director i put
a chart up here continuously that no one
in the department of treasury ended up
losing their job
in the end
accepting or receiving responsibility
for actions of misconduct was anybody in
the department of justice fired or
disciplined as a result of
the april actions in waco
no sir
i have here a schedule of disciplinary
offenses and penalties for fbi employees
one of them is listed number six is
unauthorized possession of use of or
damage to a government owned or leased
vehicle and the penalty provides a
minimum of 30-day suspension for
employee who willfully uses or
authorizes the misuses the authorized
use of a government-owned or leased
vehicle
was anyone suspended for 30 days
i just said sir there was no one who in
my uh information was uh was disciplined
as a regarded thank you
mr wise west virginia you have five
minutes
thank you mr chairman uh um one open up
um
would the panel just raise their hands
everyone who's paid by the federal
government please raise your hand
mr jamar are you not i'm retired are you
retired now do you receive a federal
retirement check yes okay
i make this point because the gentleman
from north carolina and we thank you for
your service the gentleman from north
carolina properly made the point that
the only two that two of the te
witnesses last night who incidentally
are the only two acknowledged experts in
cs gas who testified last night were
paid for by the taxpayer and he's quite
correct this whole panel with the
exception of one retired gentleman is
paid for by the federal taxpayer some of
you who've testified previously in
previous panels were paid for by the
federal taxpayer this whole bench up
here of members of congress is paid for
by the federal taxpayer this row of
staff sitting behind us and in front of
us is paid for by the federal taxpayer
this is a taxpayer paid hearing and
whether you think that it's very
fruitful hearing or at the end of it you
conclude that it was not worth a
a dime it's all paid for by the federal
taxpayer so i think we can get that
behind us and
and acknowledge
to um
mr uh
i believe mr rogers but if you if if i'm
not asking this question properly if you
just let me know and i'll direct it to
someone else in terms of the usage of cs
gas by domestic law enforcement u.s law
enforcement agencies do you have any
particular knowledge as to how many
agencies still use cs gas in this
country law enforcement agencies
no sir i don't have definitive knowledge
my impression is is that the vast
majority use it and does the fbi still
in certain situations use cs gas yes sir
it's in our inventory and indeed since
before and after waco has not the yes
fbi used cs gas on several occasions
i can't address after waco we still have
it in our field offices i noted in the
record last night information i had
received from the fbi that
of 867 state and local law enforcement
surveyed 688 maintained cs gas in their
inventory so in terms of a law enforce a
tool for law enforcement cs gas is still
considered appropriate to use is that
correct that is correct
uh
mr or i'm sorry dr salem i'm going to
turn to you
my first question is i have been handed
a curriculum vita
for dr harry salem is this i don't know
whether you can see from here is this an
accurate is this your resume yes sir and
mr chairman uh i don't know whether it's
been handed out i believe it has across
the uh both both sides of the aisle i
would ask unanimous consent that this be
made a part of the record without
objection so ordered and is
and for the us government uh
uh
do you consider yourself to be a
specialist in the area of gas and
particularly cs gas
yes i'm an inhalation toxicologist
i have spent 40 years in the field
i have edited a book on inhalation
toxicologist i have conducted
original research in respiratory
reflexes and respiratory irritants
i am the chairman of the inhalation
specialty section for the society of
toxicology i'm the editor-in-chief of
the journal of applied toxicology and
serve on the editorial board
of the journal of inhalation toxicology
thank you doctor um
did you hear the testimony last night of
dr upshaw and dr i'm dr rice
no sir okay uh
i have a lot of questions but i'm not
going to get to them in this round
apparently
let me ask you what effect would cs gas
have on children who were covered with
wet towels
dampness increases the skin irritation
of cs
but other than that
it would probably degrade the cs so that
they were not inhaling the cs
what impact would the presence of
whether the 35 knot winds or 25 knot
winds as was suggested by one witness
last night and openings and windows and
walls in the building have on the
effectiveness of cs gas that would
reduce the concentration so that the
effect
it would probably not reach the effect
of concentrations and if we're not
talking about a ten by nine by eight
foot room but instead a compound the
size of the waco compound would that
further dilute the impact of cs gas yes
sir
i have more questions at another time if
i'm able to get back thank you thank you
very much
chair yields to mr blue
thank you very much mr chairman and i
want to thank the witnesses for their
testimony i just want to ask one
clarification
yield to the chairman for some follow-up
questions uh mr jamar last night there
was some discussion with dr stone about
something that you had said
and it was a side issue but i think an
important one uh you had said something
about the fact that when the atf cattle
cars pulled up to the compound the
conditions existed for more severe
ambush and perhaps more loss of life of
the atf agents
we discussed that this morning mr schiff
um
i think the context of that was
that
um there could have been a greater
tragedy than it was but what i said
earlier was that the fact that i didn't
kill more atf agents is hardly redeeming
that's not we certainly out here but
that that's the context of that i don't
know that
why it's well
i think the point being that if the
davidians first impulse was ambush
uh then they perhaps could have and
again this is speculation uh uh
delivered a more fatal blow to more
agents well i think jim cavanaugh's
testimony is extremely clear on that the
barrage of gunfire wasn't an ambush and
they kept firing until there was a
ceasefire so i don't think there's any
question though i understand that i'm
not the killer in the atf agency the
ambush later on was not an ambush i'm
not arguing that i am saying that
conditions existed where this could have
been a worse ambush would you exist
would you agree with that oh you mean
otherwise if the if the davidians began
firing while the atf agents were still
in the cattle cars because it was very
didn't discuss that that may raise
issues of whether it was wise to uh of
the atf to pull the cattle cars up so
close uh in this engagement uh but i
just wanted to clarify that you did
think that conditions existed where it
could have been worse
if i i tell you it's it's a grace of god
that more atf agents weren't killed i
don't think he's any question about that
okay thank you very much and i would
yield a remainder of my time to chairman
zella
thank you mr blue mr sage and mr jamar
um
the the
problem that i have on this thing and
and what i is in the pit of my stomach
is watching
that building that that scenario that
tragedy the tanks going in coming out
going in
uh the loudspeakers yelling uh or
blaring out saying this is not an
assault
and it just it just doesn't if i tried
to explain this in a town meeting in new
hampshire i would have a great deal of
difficulty in trying to justify
how our government why our government
with such use of force
what we did i mean a matter of who
shoots first or
who started the fire i mean the thing
that keeps going back why was the
military there why were the tanks there
and and this is the thing that bothers
me an awful lot
and they go back to the other day which
will which is is still driving me crazy
koresha's attorneys
uh and and
and i guess uh zimmerman and de garan
uh when they were led to believe by
discussion with you that they had plenty
of time i mean i i assume that
that that's correct i mean at least
that's that's they said that they were
told by you that they still had time
they had plenty of time that they they
had a
um
a surrender offer this was on the april
14th from koresh um
and i guess
from that point
and and you all three of you indicated
you and mr pots and mr sage it indicated
that as you reported this to your
superiors you didn't take it seriously
from that point on to the use of cs gas
did you ever say directly to koresh
we need to see proof that you are riding
the seals
or we will go in with the gas
no not at the time you're puncturing the
building but
starting april 14th when when dick
degarin told me this is the
remember this point i tried to make to
congressman hyde while ago we we sent
the tape in of arnold and tabor
which
was the basis of the idea for
dick to guerin's discussion with coerce
and he and he pitched courage on it and
he sent that letter out
okay
the the
when you meet the discussion of me
saying there's plenty of time the
context of that was he would begin
writing the manuscripts he would take
two days maybe three for each one
and he would be diligent
i mean implies he would be diligent in
that and we would we would we would wait
that's
like we had been doing however i didn't
say we'd wait for for 14 days
i just said we've got plenty of time
okay now on april 15 16 17 18
the negotiators pressed them
what's the progress how are we doing
here
are we going doing anything on the on
the transcripts on the manuscripts
and the the two conversations that
strike me
from my memory most from that was that a
discussion with judy snyder she's asking
for a word process so she can proceed we
end up sending her because she was going
to be the typist we end up sending her
some ribbons
but the main conversation though mr
chairman that that is embedded in my
mind is steve snyder steve schneider
told us for days
that he always edits he's you know
because of course his lack of education
he helps him in preparation of written
material
on the april the 18th steve snyder says
to us
dona he says i have not seen the first
page i have not editing a thing okay
this is april 18th the promise was
and even that i think there was
implication that he had been writing on
them already the promise was that there
would be a a a
manuscript every two days take about two
days here's four days we got nothing
what's that telling me well 51 days we
had nothing
okay i think that's that's the
conclusion i did not reject
the attorney's plan not at all it was
not rejected
but it does it gave course a chance to
do something to look like he might
fulfill he did not but but it on the
15th you never it never came out
that you said directly to korash that if
you don't come out with this in three
days or four days we will use the gas
well you never give somebody like an
ultimatum mr chairman okay never give
ultimately let me let me if i can just
introduce ask unanimous uh consent to
introduce his evidence this is ruth
riddle's
decoded message of the seven seals of
the book of revelation
um
this this was pulled out of the fire uh
the tapes were and then then
this this then was written up uh as
evidence that he was working on that
message on the seven seals
all they had to do was say we've got a
disc we're gonna be sending it out and i
guess the problem is that's driving me
crazy and i have great respect for all
of you i really do and and uh i've been
supported by law enforcement i will
continue to have respect for for
especially the fbi but the problem is is
were you guys listening i don't know we
were listening i've just recited to you
what we went through
i was not i had not decided that if i if
i was that impulsive what would i have
would have done something in march why
would i let dick dige on march 29th
thank you very much thanks sir
do we have time at all for me to to
comment on that issue yes you do
up to two people
thank you very much
uh
i believe you made the statement uh and
if you didn't i apologize but i want to
make sure that that it's not left on the
record that we did not take that offer
seriously we took it very seriously but
it was
the point that's been made hopefully was
that it was
yet another in a series of what we
perceive to be possibly and probably
delay tactics
uh you've introduced the uh the
transcript uh from the disc that did in
fact come out with ruth riddle
i i have some serious questions about
that because during part of the process
where we
we did press uh judy schneider as far as
uh what type of equipment she had she
this is in response to her saying at
this rate with manuel this could take me
a year because she was angling for a
laptop which we
uh considered and passed that forward we
did pass in tapes considered in pass
support you gave him tape
we we sent in tape to immediately so
that they could use those laptops and
also consider the possibility of sending
in laptops i mean could use the uh the
manual and the possibility of sending in
a laptop considered to export it didn't
dismiss anything at hand
during the course of that she indicated
to us that there were no other
facilities available
the power by this time had been turned
off for approximately 37 days how in the
world if he was working on this from the
14th how did they generate that disc
if the power had been off for 30-some
days how did they generate that disk i
would
without just accepting it at face value
i would suggest there's a possibility
that that may have been previous work
what have you it's also been reviewed
i wish i had a copy of a report i don't
think there's been a formal report
generated but we'll pursue that
and to the best of my knowledge when it
was reviewed by the
uh
baylor school of law or school of uh
religion baylor university it was found
quote not to be a scholarly work
thank you mr stage yes who on your side
okay mr schumer for five minutes okay
thank you and i'd just like to go over
two points here first again
what this all means to law enforcement
and second the question we're coming to
which i think is the 64 thousand dollar
question is could this be done any
better or any differently in terms of
law enforcement i guess until last night
sitting through all these hearings my
view
was probably not different than most
americans which is i'm getting sick and
tired of all the attacks on the atf and
the fbi
sure you guys may have fouled up
and
done a few things wrong but you acted in
good faith you were trying to enforce
the law
and we should give you the benefit of
the doubt because of the person david
koresha had to deal with
and this morning one after the next my
colleagues here have been saying i'm a
good friend of law enforcement and i
believe them to be sincere in that
but i would say that those who sort of
take way out and outlandish theories
and
use them sort of as a club to bang law
enforcement over the head their
questioning and actions in the hearing
don't follow those statements now this
morning i must say i've noticed a milder
tone towards law enforcement no talking
about darth vader helmets and things
like that
and i'm appreciative of that
the second question i have is could this
have been done any differently
and we have to take that in the context
of
once atf
bungled its part of the operation
because already then you have a siege
mentality and we'll all admit that they
bungled it particularly losing the
element to surprise to me that's the
worst thing that happened
and then the fbi came in and you guys
were there
and you know janet reno
says
she searched her soul and she couldn't
have found
a better way to do this that all the
alternatives were rotten given the
monster koresh we were dealing with
um
my questions don't relate to the use of
gas
i think that is on the verge of these
conspiratorial theories i think cs gas
it's been proven to my complete
satisfaction
dr salem was probably the right thing to
use better than any alternative
including the alternative of waiting
because then you run into the problem
that koresh would do something on his
own no question about it
my basic problem is not the use of the
gas but the thing that i wonder about
is the method with which the gas was
administered
because you're dealing with people under
siege you're dealing with koresh a
madman
and you have these i've seen the
pictures you have these huge vehicles
not the bradley fighting vehicles i'll
leave those military conspiratorial
theories to my friends who are worried
about posse comitatus but the cev
you know the cevs these um combat
engineering vehicles banging holes into
this compound
and going right up there to try and
administer the gas but the banging of
the holes which you state was necessary
to allow the gas to blow through is
quite a frightening
activity
and it seems to me it is not the type of
activity
designed to encourage people to come out
it seems it is not the kind of activity
that is designed to
create a view that we are not out to
harm you
and
so i guess my question i'd aim this at
both mr jamar and mr potts
is could you please explain
why that method was chosen what the
alternative methods might have been
and why my view
which i'm willing to admit would like to
admit uh is is wrong in is that these
vehicles are the uh were the were the
best way to go and again i am terribly
mindful of the fact
that we're you know that we have a lot
of thursday morning quarterbacking going
around
that everyone could say oh do it this
way do it that way but you guys were
under pressure the attorney general was
under pressure and any day koresh could
have lit up that compound on his own and
then everyone would be yelling at you
for waiting so long and not going in and
rescuing those kids sooner but that is
my biggest concern about this i and i'd
like uh to hear your answers both uh mr
potts first maybe in mr jamar ii
uh congressman schumer the the the
reason that uh the tanks were there in
the first place was because
for safety of the agents the only way
when you say tanks you mean these cevs
right cevs
they look sort of like tanks first
bradley vehicles there and uh those were
different those weren't the ones that
banged into the compound but go ahead
the bradley vehicles were for
transportation of the people and koresh
indicated that he could blow those 40 to
50 feet in the air we went out and we we
got cevs and also some abrams tanks we
had the gun barrels intentionally
removed from those tanks
and told koresh that these were not
offensive weapons we were not bringing
in tanks to attack his compound they
were defensive just simply to protect
our agents those same vehicles that
delivered the gas
we'd also used bradley's and and and
those same protective vehicles to
deliver milk and other things to the
compound
i realized there's a significant
difference there but i'm just saying the
only way we could travel around there
was tanks right there was not worried
about the use of tanks it's the banging
in to the compound at the time the gas
was being administered and there was a
siege-like metabolism quite a bit of
discussion sir about whether or not we
use those to try to get the gas in or
whether we set back at a distance and
fire uh ferret grenades into
these into the compound it was believed
that
by starting out with firing on them they
would believe that they we were shooting
at them
shooting bullets at them ammunition at
them and that would be more provocative
than trying to go up and put it in this
other way
uh you haven't answered about the
banging and the trying to create holes
you could still have administered it
this way and not you know the building
was shaking in the pictures that i in
the in the films that i saw the tactical
people i think are better off to answer
that in terms of why that had to occur
who is that is that mr rogers then may i
have him as my second person as opposed
to mr jamar if he's more suited to
answer it thank you mr rogers yes there
are two reasons uh
first of all we we brought in the cevs
because we were very concerned and we
haven't brought this out yet
that david korish had uh uh
law rockets okay light anti-tank weapons
that was a concern that i had based on
comments that uh
he had been making about blowing our
bradley's 40-50 feet in the air
quite frankly we had some concern that
there was some stolen military
laws that he might have possession of
didn't know know whether or not he did
but we were very concerned about it and
ultimately we brought in the cevs and
the abrams because they can they're
better equipped to withstand that kind
of uh rocket
the boom that this the cev had on it is
the only vehicle that we know of that's
armored that we could use to actually
break the outer portion of that wall two
purposes one is to make an opening to
put a
non-flammable
non-burning type of
cs into that building
and second of all we wanted to use them
to make escape openings for those people
i was very concerned about the fact that
these people may not be able to get out
of that compound particularly if the
mighty men are controlling the doors and
they have weapons i see that in fact
they've got everyone trapped
so i think if you look at the
photographs and yes i agree with you
it's an ominous sight to see
quote u.s tanks unquote military tanks
as people have called them breaking into
an american building
and i agree that's the perception
unfortunately the perception is not
always the truth
and what we're trying to do is explain
why we did it
you're saying there was no alternative
to that to doing it that way sir i think
that no better alternative
i have no knowledge of any better
alternative in trying not to provoke
them and to also protect the lives of
the agents that have that responsibility
thank you mr community thank you mr
chabot i'm point of order yes sir state
your point of view
the point of order i would like to make
is concerning our format here and asking
questions under the five-minute rule
i'm a new member to the house and i
haven't
learned perhaps how yet to to to gain
that that five minutes and turn it into
10 or 15 minutes but
i think on
what i'm seeing develop here and i'm not
sure it's just limited to one side or
another but i'm i'm seeing people
use
four and
a half minutes of their five minutes uh
editorialized lecturing whatever else
and then in the last 15 seconds ask a
question or two
to two or three members of the panel
which uh allows them to go another 10 or
15 minutes beyond answering that
question
and i think the chairman both chairmen
have been extremely fair in allowing
people to fully answer a question that
goes beyond the
the red light but again i i what i'm
seeing again as a new member over here
is an abuse of this system i'm i'm
trying in my questioning to stick to my
five minutes but if we're going to
persist
in this pattern of of talking and
lecturing for four and a half minutes
and then squeezing a question at the end
so that the entire panel can ask it then
i feel like i'm not
representing my constituents if i'm
going to limit myself strictly to five
minutes if the chair can respond uh i
think uh not only the the very fine
gentlemen from from the fbi in front of
us but all of us individually up here
have to lead by example
and uh so i think uh if we can all
kind of try to
know what the rule is and work within
that role and try not to abuse it i
think your point's well taken the chair
will try to see that it is adhered to
thank you very much mr chabot
thank you i'd like to thank my colleague
from tennessee for bringing this to the
chair's attention right before i start
questioning so
in any event
mr jamar
you testified yesterday that the gassing
of the davidian house was first
considered
very soon after the initial raid in fact
within the very first week is that
correct emergency plan yes sir okay and
that emergency uh plan this was the
emergency assault plan that's what we're
talking about right yes sir okay
and this was for use in the case of an
emergency defined as a homicide or a
homicide suicide type event which might
occur in the compound um is that correct
it was the only non-lethal means we had
to stop them from doing something like
that yes sir okay
and the report says that it was
generally agreed that if an emergency
response was warranted the fbi would use
armored vehicles to punch holes and
insert gas into the building
um
that's correct is that right sir so
basically the emergency plan is is for
all intents and purposes the plan that
ultimately occurred
with some modification yes sir okay
in fact some pretty substantial
modifications okay now
mr potts let me ask you this when when
you first heard or discussed the
emergency plan um it's my understanding
that that you were very opposed to the
idea of using gas in this concept of the
emergency plan is that right
no sir
the emergency plan came in very early on
and and tony betts began to
to examine the gas okay not to interrupt
but let me let me then rephrase my
question i thought i heard you say
before when this plan to use gas the
ultimate plan to use gas
was considered
um it's my understanding that you were
opposed to that plan is that right i i
was not in favor of going forward at
that point okay and so i think not in
favor of going forward in in ahead with
that plan means you were opposed to it
right
yeah that's right okay and you were
opposed to it i assumed because you felt
there was too much too much risk
involved is that right no it was not i
think it was more the unknown sir than
it was you know that
what we did know it was it was the
unknown in terms of what their reaction
uh might be and how we could how we
could measure that it was the unknown as
to whether or not maybe there were other
things that we might be able to do
that we had not yet tried
it was all of those questions that i
thought that we had to answer as well as
what would the effect of cs gas be on
those inside the compound okay that was
one of the things as well yes you
weren't sure about what the effects
might be on the folks within the
compound particularly the children yes
sir and i think that that's what
everyone here agrees that that that was
the particular concern that we had
now it was also
i understand there was there was a
danger of uh
of waiting uh mr jamar i think you were
concerned that there was a danger if we
waited too long one of the dangers being
that keresh
and his people might try to break out is
that right now they never did try to do
that did they
um
no they didn't no okay and in addition
to that you felt that there was the risk
of mass suicide is that right
that was the fear yes sir okay and and
that that obviously never happened at
least it didn't happen until
the gas was pumped into the building
which in essence triggered
that which we were trying to avoid which
was the mass suicide well i think the
what i did on april 19th he demonstrated
with that without any removing any all
doubt that that was his ultimate goal
and that's why i think had we waited he
would have found a way to accomplish
that well that was your opinion that
that was his ultimate goal that but i
mean based on his actions on the 19th he
demonstrated his goal very clearly he
could have had those people come out all
he had to do is walk out well his
attorneys testified that they thought
that there was a deal and we all thought
some people thought he was writing this
uh the seven seals etc and and there's
some dispute about that i understand mr
say mr segal let me ask you a question
as i understand the plan
after the gassing began
any people who left the house and and
came out were to be steered toward the
m-88 tank retrieval vehicle and the
bradley fighting vehicles basically is
that right they were to come out the
front of the compound initially the
instructions were to come out the front
of the compound walk down the driveway
just exactly as it been the plan since
the second of march to a large red cross
flag
where they would receive uh medical
attention but they were they were going
to be directed
to some degree by these fighting
vehicles the bradley fighting vehicle in
the m88 tank because that right mr jamar
is shaking i believe that's correct yes
okay now after the initial assault
and after all the flashbang grenades
that were thrown whenever anyone came
out of the building and and that i
understand happened a couple of times
and after the the gas attack
uh and after you learned that these
people expected death they expected
armageddon they figured that you all
were the babylonians
did you really expect that mothers would
lead their children towards the m88
tank retrieval vehicle and towards the
bradley fighting vehicles i mean they
thought you were the enemy and all these
things happened did you really expect
them to lead their children willingly
toward these
uh very scary looking vehicles
gentleman's time has expired you can
respond by all means two two of you
hopefully expected it
okay afraid that it would happen also we
need to add in there that
towards the latter stages of the
negotiation in part this again is a
dynamic issue uh subject to change
throughout the 51 days one of the other
things we attempted to do was to drive a
wedge between david koresh and steve
schneider or his followers to try to
convince them or to shed white or at
least plant the seed for their
consideration that korish
in their eyes instead of being a messiah
may in fact have been a false prophet in
the end times
if we had been successful in doing that
if steve would have had the capability
of carrying that forward then again that
goes to the to the possibility
that he may have been able to lead or
someone may have been able to exercise
some independent thought on behalf of
their children and get them out of there
yes sir we did hope and we did pray that
they would
make their way out of there safely thank
you
okay mr gerard
you have something to say
you're the second part of that team here
the way this thing's working
thank you
i would add that the part the gas
is designed to make you want to leave
that room
it removes all this fear of babylonia or
babylonians
fear of courage and the instinct we were
hoping for is mothers say i've got to
get out of here and i've got to get my
child out of here i'm reclaiming my
child from course
okay that's what we were after
to grab those children and come out we
couldn't have a
a normal vehicle waiting because the
people would would shoot the agents we'd
be nice to have
something that would be less threatening
to someone sitting out there with a red
cross flag
by this time i think the uh after just a
few weeks
the tanks and the bradley vehicles
didn't mean much to anybody in there it
was just one more vehicle
this was just normal part of their day
didn't bother them in any way
it's a discussion we had earlier today
why didn't those people come out in that
fire would force them to stay
and then when someone else offered to me
a thing maybe he locked him in that in
that
bunker i don't know that that's the case
that could have been i said it was
probably either the fear for their
eternal salvation it could be that he
locked him in that bunker and didn't let
him out i don't know that
but i tell you wouldn't surprise me if
he did mr chairman mr chairman um
i only took the five minutes but i just
there were such long responses i just
like to make one 10-second response and
that's it
i think everyone here acted in good
faith i believe i don't believe what
some of the people out there think that
the government was against these people
i think you all acted in good faith but
as mr hyde said early on
the people the mindset within the people
that were in that building they weren't
like you and me you know they had a
different mindset and i just think that
our government assumed that they would
take rational action on behalf of
themselves and their kids and we see
that they didn't do that because we
didn't enter the minds of the people
that were in that context in that
compound and that's where i think the
mistake was made thank you mr chabot uh
mrs thurman mr chairman
since he has revisited uh mr hyde's
comments that frankly we didn't have
enough suspicion
just a moment you have any objection
by all means thank you just one of you
i understand one moment coming up uh
mr high and i wish he was here to uh
because i don't want him to labor under
the misperception that we did not fully
explore
uh the possibilities uh exhibited by
religious considerations and so forth we
explored them to the fullest extent we
felt we could with all of the experts
that we could reach out
and several that we didn't have to reach
out for
that was not a situation where we did
not try to get into that posture of his
what he was all about but what needs to
be stressed succinctly is not one
child not one branch davidian exited
that compound based upon religious
dialogue
the only possible exception being early
on when when agent cavanaugh with our
assistants
facilitated the reading of a brief
passage of scripture and kids initially
were let out two by two we would have
done that
forever
if if that would have facilitated the
release of another child but
he did not explore that as a viable
option although we were prepared to do
it
as as long as we have to
thank you very much thank you mrs
thurman i'm just going to take a few
seconds and then i'll uh yield my time
to the gentleman from virginia
west virginia westbrook my god virginia
um
how many hours do you believe in the
this total time did you spend
working with mr koresh and dude have you
ever calculated how many hours you
actually believe you spent with him
and talking and trying to figure him out
i can
i can give you exact numbers as to how
long we talked to him on the phone but
that's that for every
hour spent talking to him on the phone
there was probably three to five hours
spent in
everything from
bible study i mean seriously i don't say
that in
ingest at all
to
talking with behavioral scientists and
so forth exhaustive hours to try to
figure him out i just i want to make
this point because i asked this very
same question to mr zimmerman and mr de
guerin and their total time was all of
32 hours
and i think that that point cannot be
forgotten that we're trying to base
testimony here that somebody says they
knew they had him and he was going to
come out on 32 hours versus the amount
of hours and time and experts that you
all brought into this so secondly um mr
rogers
this issue of the bus particularly since
we've just heard this testimony just
again about the children and the and the
the mothers
was there it's my understanding there
there was a trap door
that led down to that is that what you
found yes ma'am it was inside the
hallway at the end of the
compound
so they really could have i mean if it
had been their intention during that
time and once that gas had gone in there
that they could have gone through that
trap door got into that bus which i
assume was part of the plan because you
um took firemen in there to water it
down to cool it off to make sure that
that was a safe haven for them well that
was my hope is uh once the fire started
that they had put the children in the
bus
uh we immediately put all the fire reese
fire fire fighting resources at that end
of the compound to try to cool it down
and then we immediately uh went in with
agents underground as i've testified
to try to see if they're if they're so
you believe there was actually two ways
they could have escaped they could have
come out
side the compound or they could have
gone down here as a safe haven exactly
okay thank you and at this time i'll uh
mr rogers and did you find any kind of
impediment to their getting to that bus
no sir we didn't find anything that
would have prevented them from going in
that bus uh dr salem and mr betts uh
concerning the have you did you all
calculate the amount
calculate the amount of gas that was
injected into the compound during the
several hours of insertion
yes these calculations were done
and
the statement was made that at the end
there was an acceleration of the gas
but
my question is whether even with that
acceleration anywhere near a lethal
level was reached within that compound
from the calculations that i have seen
sir that was
many times below the lethal
concentration
and mr
bets do you concur with that
absolutely i was present during the
calculations and all the considerations
that were given to the calculation dr
salem much has been said about your
conversations with the attorney general
she of course will be here monday you
spoke somewhat about that is there
anything you'd like to add to the brief
that you maybe have not had a chance to
in your briefing of the attorney general
and how you advised her about the
impact of cs gas upon those within the
compound both adults and children well
as i said at the outset
the advice i gave that if a chemical was
to be used
the safest and most potent ride control
agent was cs
and based on the literature
there are no
validated
uh reports where people have died
following its use
both infants and adults and elderly and
in the briefing you were giving to the
attorney general were you
calculating the amount of cs gas that
would be introduced and what you were
maybe i should rephrase that did you in
your briefing did you assume the same
level that actually was inserted into
the compound i was not involved in any
of the operational or tactical
uh
discussions i thought that
they would have
experts to decide on how much to put in
it was after the fact that i'd seen the
calculations but the levels
of effective concentrations and the
lethal concentrations and safety factors
i believe were discussed
but if i might mr chairman but in fall
in final quest note given the amount
that was actually inserted would that if
you'd known that was to be the amount
would it have changed your
advice to the attorney general in any
way uh the concentrations that were
actually
achieved according to calculations no
sir thank you
okay mr taylor
mr taylor
does this mean there are no further
republican witnesses
no
okay we have uh
all right i guess since i would like to
proceed in the normal order i i still
have time till
hold on uh chair recognize mrs shattuck
thank you mr chairman and in a moment
i'll yield the balance of my time i just
wanted to ask one uh
brief question because i'm a little
confused about it
mr jamar in your testimony today
um
you have
as i've listened to it suggested that
the
people at the waco facility uh inside
the davidian compound
committed suicide
uh
you don't have any evidence that the
children inside the compound committed
suicide do you no i was speculating on
why they didn't come out okay and they
were some several were shot and then
shot where it was not apparent without
being suicide so that's i think it was a
murder i think a fair description of the
event and the loss of those lives is a
murder suicide so any
well
there again any statement by you
that they committed suicide or you think
this was a suicide or that it appears to
have been a suicide or that it was a
suicide or that they committed suicide
or that they fulfilled their prophecy to
commit suicide
since we never got to talk to them is
all
a conclusion that you've drawn
and as you just said speculation on your
part a lot of survivors are saying it
wasn't a suicide pact
so who do you you know i'm speculating
i'm trying to i'm trying to
to resolve in my mind why someone would
sit in there for six hours with gas
and not come out with the full
opportunity to come out who was keeping
them from doing it are they compelling
themselves or what i don't know i'm just
it has to be speculation i i think
that's the point is we don't know for
example we know that broadcasts were
were intended to go in and were made
saying you can come out
but we don't know because we were never
able to talk to those who died we don't
know if any of the children heard those
broadcasts we don't know for a fact that
any of the mothers heard those
broadcasts
we don't know that they heard the full
broadcast
we just don't know
that they
understood they could leave and would be
fine and therefore by staying we're
committing suicide well those children
were kept in there from march the 5th i
don't think those children had any idea
that they had a choice about anything
so they clearly did not commit suicide
and we could just assume the children
did not commit suicide
murder suicide
children were murdered if he didn't let
him come out he murdered them
they didn't commit suicide right
they did not i said it's a murder so
some did some some persons in that place
committed suicide we were just talking
about the children okay the children
were murdered by courage the children
did not commit suicide they were
murdered by courage that's your
conclusion they were they did not commit
suicide
because they were murdered by courage
sir did they commit suicide
no thank you
i yield the balance of my time to mr
zelloff
thank you um i mr potts i just have one
quick question before i yield my balance
of time to
uh mr mccullum
um
in your testimony am i correct in
understanding that that at no time at
ruby ridge you had in your operational
plan
um any thought of using cs gas or other
chemical agents
no sir there i'm sorry here it is
there was consideration being given
to using cs gas there was discussion
about using cs gas
there was never a decision to go forward
with cs gas or approve the use of cs gas
there but but
was it in the plan
to consider using it i don't know
whether it was in the plan or not but it
was just read a paragraph here um
on august 23 1992 the above actions will
be repeated if no response from the
compound is received the apc's will be
prepared to begin destruction of
portions of the structures inside the
compound these destructions will not
include the major living areas of the
main residence if no response is
received at this time arcs will be
prepared to deliver chemical agents into
the residence in anticipation of
conducting an entry into same
there's no approval for to go forward
with the
with putting cs gas in to
that location
okay i i guess what concerns me is the
rules of engagement at both locations
and the use of gas
but uh i now yield to mr mccollum thank
you for yielding i want to get a quick
question in if i can hear about the
questions of the breakout and i'd like
to ask this with mr jamar mr rogers uh
it is my understanding from looking at
the report that the justice department
did on the meeting of the 14th it looks
like the 14th of april where
mr rogers you were present and some of
the key military that advisors who were
advising the attorney general on the gas
were meeting in the gas plan
that it was asserted by the military
advisers they did not believe that
maintaining the hostage rescue team in a
constant state of readiness was possible
and that perhaps the hrt should be
withdrawn and further training be done
with them there's also the question
that's been raised in a lot more that
i'm not going to read here
about maintaining the perimeter that the
fbi regarded the perimeter security is
so significant that it urged the
attorney general to relieve the htr with
swat teams only as
a last resort i'm a little confused
about this uh it it
it seems to me mr jamar that you have
told us that you were worried quite a
bit for some time preceding this final
assault uh that with the fact that the
davidians with courage might break out
they might
try to use children as a shield and move
out
it also occurs to me that there was a
concern
at least expressed by military advisers
and i gather though it's not in this
text from other sources that perhaps mr
rogers didn't fully agree that the hrt
needed to retrain or regroup but i
assume over a period of time that that
was a consideration that had this siege
going on for another few weeks
certainly your men would have been very
tired i also gather that's one of the
reasons why
mr potts had made the recommendation in
his testimony or made the changes that
are in the testimony today
to put swat teams developed by the fbi
for the future
under the hrt command my question is
this can you corroborate that to what
and what significance was the fact in
your decision-making of going forward
within the gas assault the the concern
of the breakout the concern of the
tiredness potentially and the need to
retreat and regroup at some point of the
hrt
and
to what degree did you consider and why
would you have discarded it if you did
the use of local
officials of sheriff's departments or
swat teams from perhaps the the state
police the texas police
or whoever else was available
at least to
guard the area at some distance away to
make this area secure
uh mr rogers and mr jamar
the reason that
we felt the hrt was the proper
unit to maintain that perimeter
is we've already talked about the use of
military vehicles uh the team members
were trained as drivers they were
familiar with the safety of those
vehicles we had
certain
electronic and other type equipment that
is unique to our team
quite frankly the u.s government has put
a lot of money into that team in order
to try to make it the best in the world
and those particular items that we we
use
when you get into night equipment night
vision equipment etc
the other team's not trained for our
team is a full-time team the swat teams
train maybe once or twice a month
so when you compare the level of
equipment sophistication the training
there's clearly no other option in my
mind you ask the question about the
meeting with the attorney general i
believe
i believe she asked me whether or not
the team was tired
and i said no the team wasn't tired but
i agreed with what the military
personnel had
had noticed and that is that had they
had the same kind of unit under the same
kind of conditions they would be looking
to pull them out for retraining and what
we're talking about are the very
perishable skills that the team has that
had not been exercised in
in 50 days
we're also talking about cognitive
skills uh decision making judgment type
skills which tend to degradate when you
keep people on the line
for as long as we did as an example i
had snipers that physically stayed in
position for 11 days before they ever
came came out of the sniper position
therein
looking and watching and reporting the
intelligence that takes a large toll on
on these kinds of people not that
they're physically tired but it's those
other skills are referred to and mr
jamar and you are now going to answer
not only respond to that but to what
degree was as i asked was this a factor
in your concern with when you did the
assault in other words the need to do it
whether it's on the 19th or if you had
to do it within a few how long you could
actually do it two or three weeks later
or at some point
how urgent was was your concern over the
hrt team's skills and the ability uh to
have them prepared and to maintain that
perimeter to your final decision okay
let's
let me make sure i remember to answer
this for you when you said the breakout
i wouldn't worry about him escaping i
was worried about him for being shot
down understood let's make that clear
uh it was not short-term concern for me
it was a long-term concern it did not i
did not say we need to do this day after
tomorrow because hrt is tired not at all
that's weeks away in my opinion that's
what i wanted weeks away not far as i'm
the great concern about the with what mr
rogers just described it was not a
matter of days to me it would have been
weeks all right thank you very much yes
sir
mr taylor
i want to just open this up to the panel
and if you would the fairly simple
questions yes or no
the testimony of mr quresh's attorneys
the one who said he gathered his 15
children around him
and only three of them were lawfully in
his name did that pretty well convince
you that he was having children out of
wedlock by girls as young as 12 and 13.
have you followed the hearings
because it convinced me
yes did the
post
operative search of the building
convince you that there were illegally
converted machine guns on the premises
at least 48 of them
yes or no
sir i'm sorry there was testimony in the
trial that there were 48 at least 48 yes
sir okay so you're convinced of that
yes sir were there also hand grenades
found yes sir and you made mention now
of uh
light anti-tank weapons concern for that
yes just concerned if they weren't found
okay we didn't recover anything they did
find some uh inert rpg's rocket
propelled grenade projectile i know what
an rpg is sir thank you
there was also
a woman who claims
kept her
against her will
for three months
another says quresh compiled a hit list
of former members that he was going to
have eliminated his words not mine
do you gentlemen believe in family
values
absolutely absolutely do you think
that's the kind of family values that
this congress pledged to
bring to the american people
you people believe in personal
responsibility because that leads to the
next question we've always said that
several members of this pound and other
panels that said if crash had just told
those kids
and those old people to get up and walk
out of here
they would have done it after all
children were sleeping with him old
people were giving him everything they
owned husbands were giving their wives
to him never done anything he said
including get up and walk out of fear
but he was using them as human shields
wasn't he
mr taylor can can i bring something up
to you that has really bothered me yes
sir can you do that on your time sure
okay the answer to your question is not
only yes but that specific statement was
made to david and to steve that he knows
full well that if he directs those
people to come out they will come out
and we ask them to do that okay that's
why i'd like you to comment on
something that appeared in one of the
local rags
that's a statement
and it says what the government's
assault on the deviance davidians
compound succeeded in doing
whether out of compassion or vainglory
or a combination of both
what's to kill them
now if you believe in family values
and you believe in personal
responsibility how can anyone who
believes in personal responsibility
say the quresh accepted his
that's not personal responsibility
that's hiding behind women and children
i mean i have seen witness after witness
brought by these folks first saying the
crest was just a simple old country
preacher who had a couple weapons and
yeah he was having sex with 11 to 12
year olds but that's okay
and yeah he did have a little hit list
but we don't want to hear from that
witness and yes he kept people against
their will we don't hear from that
witness and the other reporters who
wrote about him and demanded local law
enforcement do something about it they
left town for fear for their lives we
don't want to hear from them they
changed the markings on their car they
changed the locks on the newspaper we
don't want to hear from them
how can anyone justify and then they
bring a doctor who says that because
only four atf agents were murdered there
wasn't really an ambush
and they're trying to paint themselves
as pro law enforcement
gentlemen you are the thin blue line
between the laws we write and anarchy
and i appreciate what you're doing
and i want to ask this panel like i've
asked to have any every panel before you
is there anything that you've seen or
heard or read justify the murder of
those four atf agents or in any way wars
david koresh's hands
for the deaths of those 80 old people
women and children
i'm going to make it a little bit longer
than before
and please mr rogers i still got a
little time to jump in thank you sir no
i've seen absolutely nothing
i also would like to go back to a point
you made about the weapons inside
it's my belief that had he planned on
coming out he would have reconverted the
automatic weapons into semi-automatic
because that's the best evidence to put
him in jail or those automatic weapons
which we recovered
would everyone like to answer the
question of whether anything you've seen
or read or heard justifies the murders
of the agents or washes david karan's
hand crashes hands for the death of
those 80 people nothing
okay we're limited to two mr taylor
you got your two you cannot
uh in dealing with the other side as a
practicing attorney
and uh i'm not sitting in in second
judgment of you as mr sage okay no
that's that's that's an accurate
representation that's why we cycled the
majority of our negotiators came in on
about a two-week that's why you have a
negotiating team that's correct right
keep it correct keep it going now while
you were going through these
negotiations were you being briefed
by whomever is monitoring the listening
devices are they saying here's what
they're talking about here's what our
senses are here's what their emotions
are here's where
yes no periodically we would have the
the daily briefings which would uh bring
up topics if there was something that
was that was absolutely significant
that would be brought to the attention
through what we refer to as situation
reports sit reps it would be
channeled to
any of any aspect of the command that
needed
to know that information immediately
would obviously go into the on-scene
commander but often they would come in
or route that into us and either
gary nesner who was here yesterday who
was one of the coordinators or clint van
zant or myself as the day team leader uh
would go over and make sure the team was
aware of it all right thank you
mr potts did mr hubbell ever tell you
that either he or the president wanted
to approve any shift in the negotiation
plan that's one question the other
question is did mr hubbell ever tell you
that he had spoken to the president and
the president wanted the siege to be to
be ended and understood that cs was how
it was to be done
uh no i heard that uh the
from
stewart gerson who told director
sessions who told me that the president
had indicated that he wanted to be
advised if there was a change in the
strategy from negotiation
and that was early on in this
i'm sorry the second the second question
did mr hubb will ever tell you that he
had spoken with the president and the
president wanted the siege to end and
understood that the cs was how it was to
be done no sir
all right so the first time the
president really learned about the cs
was this meeting on the 18th that the
attorney general then had with the
president
i don't know i don't know sir i'll have
to ask the attorney general on monday i
believe so all right thank you
appreciate you gentlemen thank you thank
you very much chair now recognize mr
barr for five minutes
thank you mr chairman uh mr potts there
has been some discussion today of
ruby ridge and the
consideration being given to the
introduction of tear gas or cs gas there
and do you have with you a document date
at 8 23 92 fbi slash usms op plan
bonners ferry idaho
no sir okay let me ask a clerk to
deliver this to mr potts please now
direct your attention to
paragraph two and while that's being
brought over i'd like to read a
operative portion of it
on august 23 1992 the above actions will
be repeated if no response from the
compound is received the apc's armored
personnel carriers will be prepared to
begin destruction of portions of the
structure inside the compound
this destruction will not include the
major living areas of the main residence
if no response is received at this time
arcs will be prepared to deliver
chemical agents into the residence in
anticipation of conducting an entry into
same
was that the ops plan
sir it's i don't know i don't have all
this is that document or is that
document not the ops plan very simple
question no no sir it's not as simple
okay
where is the ops plan if this is not
i i don't know sir i don't have that
ops plan you can
is this or is this not the ops plan
i don't know you don't know were you
there i don't know no i was not there
did you ever have an ops plan
there there were several have you ever
seen an ops plan for it
for that yes for that
yes okay is this the ops plan i don't
know whether it's the same one or not
you don't have any recollection of
whether it is or is not i do not know i
think that's a very disingenuous
response no sir it's not i think it is
uh
dr salem
uh if i could and
i understand that that there's a great
desire on the part of everybody
connected with this to deny that
anything that that we did our government
did cause the death of the children
there
and i understand your testimony that
cs gast
would not directly
or would not likely directly cause the
death of a child i understand that
uh we do have at least one
autopsy photo here we talked about this
last night it's in the record
uh medical examiner photo of uh doe 57 a
six to eight-year-old girl
cause of death asphyxia inflammation in
throat and lungs and there was some
testimony last night by a medical doctor
that that that would be
consistent with
possibly consistent with gas
my my question really
is one is is is that possible
and and i like your objective opinion
because i don't think you really have
any axe axe to grind here uh no sir i
don't is it possible that that the cs
gas
uh would cause uh inflammation in the
throat and lungs of a six to eight year
old cs gas is an irritant and it does
cause irritation of the mucous membrane
you might want to pull that a little bit
closer
cs is a respiratory irritant it causes
inflammation of the mucous membranes
which line the respiratory tract
to get to
uh where the inflammation is that great
you're going to need a very high
concentration sir
to get to that it may be a combination
of the blankets that were put over the
children plus
no i i understand that in exactly if you
exclude all of the oxygen is it pot is
it possible that that it could have
caused
inflammation in the throat and lungs of
a six to eight year old girl
yes it is possible that the cs can do
that uh also
with regard to
the introduction of cs and methylene
chloride
that was being injected into the end of
the building right
and then there was a fire that started
and i don't want to get into what caused
the fire to get started we all agree
that there was a fire that started
would the burning
uh and
the cs the combination of the cs and the
methylene chloride
in the building
and the burning
have generated toxic substances such as
hydrogen cyanide
methylene dichloride i don't believe
causes
or generates uh hydrogen cyanide
but during the burning process yes
hydrogen cyanide is released from the
burning of many materials such as wood
plastic
uh
fabrics okay so so the fire with all of
these chemicals it could i'm not asking
you to render an opinion that it did but
it could have generated uh hydrogen
cyanide yes sir and that being the case
uh is it certainly not a reasonable
presumption that that substance being in
the compound in the building where
people
are located also
could that have inhibited in some way
their ability to get out of the building
yes
the gentleman is entitled to his
questions and i hope you all yield him
some time to answer him but he has gone
well beyond the red and i just want to
make that point that's so nutty
please answer the question just two of
you and then i only need one i don't i
don't want it okay necessarily two i
mean i'm just trying to limit it here
just to dr salem okay
experiments have shown that when you
have
i believe
550 milligrams per cubic meter in an
enclosed chamber
the amount of cyanide that's generated
i'm sorry at 10 milligrams per cubic
meter which is what a trained soldier
can tolerate
and
the amount of cyanide generated is less
than 2 30 milliliter puffs of a
cigarette cigarette smoking also
generates hydrogen cyanide
so if that puts that in perspective
gentlemen's time has been inspired i
just that that
that doesn't answer the question i'd
just like to if i could remind the
witness what what the question was okay
well on that basis uh
i'm not going into another area of
income dr salem could you try to answer
the question that is simply whether or
not given the fact that these substances
could have been generated by the
combination of these chemicals in there
and the burning
and hydrogen cyanide possibly having
been created
could that have interfered with with
somebody leaving
inhibited they're leaving the building
using sir because
again it depends on the concentration
sir but it's high enough it's possible
okay
i think i think that's uh thank you just
about done it on both sides here uh
mr mccollum final five minutes thank you
very much mr chairman i just want to
make one comment dr salem and and it is
no reflection you're a fine toxicologist
got a great record obviously know a lot
about cs gas and we're called upon for
that reason but there is an irony in the
fact that it came out today that you've
not been published on the cs gas
question and last night mr schumer was
making a huge uh noise over here on our
side of the aisle that several of the
people on the panel other toxicologists
had not been published so i no
reflection on you just the observation
now i want to ask one or two quick
questions mr rogers i want to know if
you agree with mr jamar that your hrt
unit could have stayed on the scene
there without needing to withdraw for
refresher training or whatever for weeks
more than the april 19th assault
they could have physically stayed there
that would not have precluded the
degradation of their skills though sir
and if they could degradation of the
skills got great enough you'd had to
have some kind of augmentation whether
that was um
as well trained people or not in order
to maintain the perimeter is that not
true
we would have to have uh those those
comparable skills in order to maintain
the perimeter all right and all right
how long could they have stayed there
before you think that have been a real
problem or you would have had to
withdraw some in order to maintain the
perimeter
i think within uh a matter of uh a
couple of weeks we'd be looking to
have some kind of remedy to the problem
all right mr potts did you know
that mr jamar felt 99 certain that the
davidians would would fire on the cevs
thereby making the accelerated use of cs
gas probable
before the assault on the 19th
i certainly didn't understand that he
believed that there was a 99 chance when
when i spoke to him
in late march on the phone
we talked about what the response would
be of the davidians if we put gas in and
he said i believe they'll shoot and
i said i don't how can we go forward if
we believe that there's that strong a
chance that that they will shoot
what what i believed had been developed
as a result of our trip to waco
with along with mr clark was a plan
which everybody believed significantly
decreased the chances of them firing on
us when we inserted them but if you'd
known mr jamar felt that way would you
have had different advice for the
attorney general
i would have conveyed it up the line and
and um
i i think that the decision made makers
would have would have had to
to to significantly consider that i
believe that we had significantly
reduced that that risk i want to clarify
something with mr sage and mr jamar in
the last segment of questions
earlier today you said mr sage that
mr hubble had been told by you about the
plan of the 14th of april and we went
over that last night you've been over at
almost ad nauseum i think i understand
what you're saying i just want to
clarify it
i'll ask you at the end of the
questioning last night about this you
and mr jamar
and i specifically put the concerns i
had in terms not of a surrender plan
which i understand you distinguish and
so forth not in terms of the fact that
de garan was working uh on trying to get
these folks
uh to write the seven seals
interpretation or get courage to do that
not in terms of those generic things but
in the specific terms that concern me
which i think you answered for me
which may have had a different slant if
you will or different viewpoint or
perspective than the simple answer you
gave earlier today to that question that
was asked you did mr hubbell know about
the discussions and and the goings on
with the garrett i asked it in terms of
things such as what dr tabor
had had said at one point and the
interpretation that de garin was making
as i understood it that if you moved
against the compound with the bradleys
uh even if accompanied by declarations
of an assault the very acts of
aggression
would be interpreted by korish as a
confirmation of god's mission to him
as a martyr or to be a martyr rather
than
to be a a messenger which is what de
garin explicitly discussed with us and
tabor did in their testimony the
attorney for courage and and the
religious professor
and in terms of the fact that it was
their view
which had been expressed to you as i
understood it and how much detail i'm
not clear
that at this stage at the 14th of april
uh that there had been a change of
attitude by korish that they they felt
very strongly that korish at that point
was being persuaded actually they felt
he'd already been persuaded that to be
the messenger that he was the messenger
that indeed it wasn't the fifth seal it
wasn't the martyr in the book of
revelation that he was to be for for as
god's martyr in this sense the messiah
that came in that apocalyptic sense but
rather
that he was to have a chance to be the
messenger to to release himself from the
the bondage of the building where he was
housed and ultimately while in jail he
could still talk about this
uh and and they felt that in large
measure because of what had gone on they
said as a joyous
occasion in there they saw all the
people reacting really believing they
were coming out and all that what i'm
getting at is and i don't want to
belabor this but what you said to me
last night if i'm not mistaken and i
don't think i am is that you did not
convey you did not believe you conveyed
that
type of detail that type of sense of
what de garron and tabor were talking
about to hubble
uh and i think mr jamar was confirming
that you you two just didn't see it that
way that was not you didn't see this as
that
in that detailed sense of the religious
message uh as something to convey at the
time of the two-hour telephone
conversation or
and as i think i asked ms jamar did you
ever convey that yourself to anybody up
in washington and i think his answer was
no as i recall it could you elaborate on
that and explain that to me i just want
to be sure i'm right
and i'm a little confused as to the
question frankly the question is whether
or not
you
get your own for quite a while well i i
i'd like to respond he's finally gotten
around to asking the question well i was
asking the expert newly noted
the question is very simple the question
is
did you convey to mr hubbell
the de garin perspective
that korich had indeed uh had an
attitude change in de garin's opinion i
knew that wasn't your opinion
and that that attitude change was that
he was now viewing himself as the
messenger and that that's why daguerreon
had such a strong hope
as confirmed by tabor's views of the
tapes at all that came out later that
there would be an opportunity for
uh
the doris to pursue these pieces of
paper these writings
and and even more likely come out
did you convey that to hubble that was
the question i asked you last night you
said you didn't convey that to it as i
recall now
what i said last night what i've said
today and what i will say again is that
the issue regarding the transcripts was
in fact discussed with mr hubbell i
spent a great deal of time last night
trying to
refresh my memory trying to get that
back into context so that it could be
just as clear and candid with you as
possible but in the proper context
because therein lies a problem this has
been blown way out of context or way out
of of
perspective as far as the importance
placed
the day after this thing was brought
forward
was nowhere near as great as you've been
led to believe by the defense counsel i
wish
that it would have had the merit that
they attempted to convey to this
committee or these subcommittees
i i think we all wish that but that was
not the case it wasn't the case then it
wasn't our perception one day after it
had been brought forward but we did not
dismiss it
we continued to pursue it and and that's
evidenced by uh
the negotiation transcripts which we'll
be happy to make available the bottom
line is that you didn't convey that
strong an impression to hubble because
you didn't feel it was ever given
that's wrong i conveyed to him the
impression that was given to us and i'm
telling you that it was not that strong
not that i didn't feel it was that
strong it had never been conveyed that
strongly to us and this was one day
after the the whole concept had been
brought forward it wasn't
it was fully conveyed to him in the
context with which it had been presented
to us gentleman's time has
expired mr tamara you want to comment on
it i think
that we did
hope that was there was something to
that
someone asked me would we do the letter
this is
an analysis by a psycholinguistic
linguistics expert
of the three letters april 10th 11th and
14th his conclusion was
in some i do not believe there is any
writings any better or at least certain
hope i'm sorry in some i do not believe
there is in these writings any better or
at least certain hope for an early in
for an early end to the siege now he
he's when he's analysis he says
the third letter the fourth letter the
14th is a content duplicate of
the first letter that was sent on the
10th okay this is part of this
series of letters from him
my point to you is it was it was not
simple our opinion we all it wasn't
limited to my opinion and and mr sage's
opinion there were other people involved
in the analysis of the probability of a
change of heart or mind of mr korish
so but
mr guerin took that very seriously i saw
mr mr arnold out in the hall here a
while ago and the thing we discussed
yesterday about me looking for what was
this change what wasn't i asking because
i asked your staff help me find that
because i like to understand that where
they got that idea that there was this
joy in in
inside the compound
i did not detect that in any way i'll
read it the pilot of the uh over here is
last night trying to find
is there a discussion of the new david i
didn't detect any but that the magma of
the microphone was very limited
okay
i didn't detect any of the stuff i read
in the transcripts but i'd have time to
read all the three days four days
transcripts that's why i asked the staff
to help me find where in those
transcripts where we find something of
this this new joy inside the compound
i think it was mystic mr de garan's
drive to like i said this morning this
is a this is a man used to succeeding
he was driving he was doing his best
this is our last hope of these people
because they knocked his legs off him on
the previous
april 4th he put it in there because he
had his heart and soul in it i believe
mr mr arnold had his heart and soul in
it
and we had our heart and soul in it i
understand i think but we did not
dismiss this out of hand we gave this a
chance and i explained to mr arnold
while i go and he tried i said what
about steve saying to us hey i'm the
editor you're not getting anything until
i see i'm paraphrasing please
you're not getting anything until i edit
i haven't seen the first page this is
the fourth day
i just don't think they had their heart
in it sir understand thank you thank you
mr chairman thank you mr chairman uh
one quick uh question uh mr potts is
there any chance that you could uh
there's a lot of interest in in having a
second round of questions here
but we could resolve that is there any
chance that you could join the fbi panel
on monday morning uh yes sir okay thank
you very much and that that'll solve a
big big problem
um i just would like to say to all of
you
you have our thanks on both sides of the
aisle for being here
uh what you're going through is not easy
i'm sure and what you went through
on april 19th was not easy as well and
we thank you for being here the joint
oversight uh committee assistant
chairman unanimous consent request over
here yes uh if i could have unanimous
consent that the document that i'd uh
handed to uh mr potts earlier which he
referred to which i referred to be
included in the record without objection
so ordered thank you
mr chairman yes mr i'm i'm up here
okay yes mr potts yes sir
the fbi prepared a statement a written
statement could i ask that that be
entered into the record without
objection so ordered thank you thank you
anybody else
okay the uh the joint oversight
committees uh on waco stand uh recess
until 8 30 tomorrow morning in the other
hearing room next door
department
perfect
[Music]
this concludes day seven of the house
waco hearings tomorrow see the eighth
day of the hearings witnesses are former
fbi director william sessions and
webster hubble former associate attorney
general
it was not a dream
tomorrow we'll show the eighth day of
last month's house waco hearings we'll
hear more from fbi official larry potts
also testifying former fbi director
william sessions and former associate
attorney general webster hubble
and another panel of arson and fire
experts
the ninth day of hearings airs thursday
with a panel of fbi special agents
and on friday we'll air the final day of
the house hearings with testimony from
attorney general janet reno
wednesday ross perot testifies at a
medicare hearing before the senate
finance committee we'll have live
coverage on our companion